GOOD
MORNING I I'M ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CUDDY PETRIE-NORRIS I AM CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THE ORANGE COUNTY OIL SPILL
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
TODAY'S JOINT HEARING ON
STRATEGIES FOR DECOMMISSIONING
OFFSHORE OIL INFRASTRUCTURE. LET
ME JUST COVER A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS BEFORE WE JUMP INTO THE
HEARING ARE WE ARE REQUIRING
THAT MASKS BE WORN BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. ACTS AT
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE FIFTEEN
FOLLOWING OUR PANELISTS WE WILL
BE OPENING UP AT THE HEARING FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT F. AT THAT TIME I
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC PRESENT
IN THE HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK I CAN RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIAE TIME. BOB REMOTE
TESTIMONY INFORMATION FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE OVER THE
PHONE HI YOU MAY FIND
INSTRUCTIONS TO DO SO ON OUR
SELECT COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND-
THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IS. 877-692-8957
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO
AND ALL REVIEW THAT INFORMATION
AGAIN WHEN WE JUMP INTO THAT.
PORTION OF THE HEARING- AGAIN
THANK YOU AT WELCOME EVERYONE I
WANT TO THANK THE PANELISTS HERE
TODAY FOR TAKING- TO SHARE
EXPERIENCES AND RECOMMENDATIONS
. YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND
LEADERSHIP ARE REALLY CRITICAL
AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO BUILD A
CLEANER FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA.
OP WE ARE HERE TODAY- BECAUSE ON
THE EVENING OF OCTOBER FIRST A
BROKEN PIPELINE ON AND OFF SHORE
PLATFORMS IN FEDERAL WATERS OFF
THE COAST OF HUNTINGTON BEACH
BEGAN TO SPEW THOUSANDS OF
GALLONS. OF POST PRODUCTION OF
CRUDE OIL INTO THE BEAUTIFUL
COASTAL WATERS OF ORANGE COUNTY
AND SAN DIEGO. A UNIFIED COMMAND
TEAM WAS SIMPLY SWIFTLY
MOBILIZED TO IMPLEMENT EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND CLEANUP AND ON
DECEMBER TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE UNIFIED COMMAND
DID ANNOUNCE THAT THE CLEAN UP
EFFORT HAD CONCLUDED. THE
PIPELINE IS SECURE THE OIL HAS
BEEN REMOVED FROM THE PIPELINE
IT HAS BEEN FLUSH WITH WATER AND
TESTED. AND INVESTIGATION INTO
THE INCIDENT HAS REALLY ONLY
JUST BEGUN AND THE FULL
INVESTIGATION IS EXPECTED TO
TAKE UP TO SEVERAL WEEKS YEARS
AND AT COULD RESULT IN BOTH
CIVIL AS WELL AS CRIMINAL.
LIABILITIES WE CONDUCTED A
HEARING ON AT THE END OF LAST
YEAR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE. AT
LOOKING INTO OPPORTUNITIES FOR
US TO IMPROVE OUR OIL SPILL
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
STRATEGIES AS THE STATE I. THE
CLEARLY BOTH NOT IT FROM THIS IS
THAT FROM THE DISASTER THAT
RESULTED IN THE CREATION OF OUR
SELECT COMMITTEE IS REALLY CLEAR
WHEN WE DRILL WE SPELL AND THE
GOAL OF TODAY'S HEARING. IS TO
BUILD OUR KNOWLEDGE AND OUR
UNDERSTANDING AT FOR ALL OF THE
FACTORS THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER
AS WE LOK TO DECOMMISSION
OFFSHORE OIL. INFRASTRUCTURE OFF
THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA TODAY
WILL BE I DIGGING INTO A NUMBER
OF. FIVE HAVE. A CONVERSATIONS
FOCUSED AROUND COST
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS WORKFORCE
TRANSITION LIABILITY
CONSIDERATIONS I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY.
REALLY TO LEARN FROM OUR
PANELISTS HERE TODAY AND- TO
CONTINUE ON A PATH TO DEVELOP AN
EXPEDITED PHASE OUT PLAN FOR
DECOMMISSIONING. OFF BEFORE WE
MOVE TO OUR FIRST PANEL I'D LIKE
TO ASK IF ANY OF OUR OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE AN OPENING STATEMENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE. WELL
GOOD MORNING. AND THANK YOU FOR.
PULLING THIS HEARING TOGETHER
ALONG WITH A CHAIR THREE OF US-
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT GOES
INTO GETTING THESE HEARINGS
TOGETHER AND- AND I KNOW WE ALL
WANT TO THANK- ARSED STAFFS AND
THE SELECT COMMITTEE STAFF FOR.
PUTTING HEARING TOGETHER THANK
YOU AGAINST YOUR COLLEAGUE
PETRIE-NORRIS. AS CHAIR OF
BUDGET SUB THREE AND WE HAVE-
THREE DIFFERENT COMMITTEES THAT
ARE REPRESENTED HERE- AT TODAY
AT THE AT THE- SELECT COMMITTEE.
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND UP MY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON CLIMATE
CRISIS RESOURCES ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION AND IN MY
CAPACITY I'M- REALLY ALL TOO
FAMILIAR WITH THE SUBSTANTIAL
COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
DECOMMISSIONING JUST LAST YEAR
WE INCREASED THE FUNDING TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE. STAFF TO
PREVENT OIL SPILLS BUT WE ALSO
SPENT FIFTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
TO PLUG AND ABANDON AN OFFSHORE
WELL IN SANTA BARBARA. WITH THE
TOTAL STATE COSTS NOW
APPROACHIG SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH DOESN'T EVEN COVER
THE ENTIRE COST OF.
DECOMMISSIONING THIS ONE
PLATFORM. AS WE EXPLORE
STRATEGIES FOR DECOMMISSIONING.
I'M VERY CONCERNED TO AND HOPE
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT HOW WE
ENSURE THAT EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS PROPERLY
MAINTAINED. AND WHAT MEASURES
ARE IN PLACE TO ENSURE SAFE
OPERATION WITH AGING WHILE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE MUST ENSURE.
THAT THE RESPONSIBLE PARTIES PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE TO PROTECT OUR
COAST AND INLAND AREAS FROM OIL
DESTRUCTION. I WHEN I COULD I
BECAME- TH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF A NONPROFIT LOS ANGELES AND
NUMBER YEARS AGO AND IT WAS IN
DOWNTOWN LA AND- THE LOT NEXT
DOOR HAD A STRANGE LOOKING CAP-
VALVE SYSTEM ON IT IT TURNED OUT
THAT- THIS WAS A VESTIGE OF AN
OIL WELL THAT WENT BACK ALMOST
TO THE FOUNDING OF LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE OIL HAS BEEN- IN LA- OIL
WAS KING FOR A ARE FOR QUITE A
TIME AND THERE REALLY WEREN'T
ANY RULES AT ALL AROUND
DECOMMISSIONING OIL WELLS AT
THAT TIME. THE WELLS WERE
SHALLOW AND I LEARNED THAT-
PEOPLE ACTUALLY WHEN THE WILL
WAS DEPLETED JUST STARTED
THROWING GARBAGE IN THE PIT THAT
WAS LEFT FROM FROM THE WELL-
WE'VE OBVIOUSLY COME A LONG WAY
FROM THAT TIME- BUT WE'RE NOT
WHO ARE CLEARLY HOT ALL THE WAY
THERE YEAH AND- ALSO THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE HERE. OUR
PREVIOUS HEARING WAS VERY
INFORMATIVE AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS IN ABOUT TO. ABOUT THE
HISTORY AND FUTURE OF OFFSHORE
DRILLING IN OUR STATE. AND
STRATEGIES FOR DECOMMISSIONING
AND TRANSITIONING AS WE-
CONTINUE TO TRANSITION AWAY FROM
OUR DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUEL AS
WE MUST. WE NEED TO DEVELOP
POLICY SOLUTIONS THAT ADDRESS
THE NEAR TERM IMPACTS OF
CONTINUED PRODUCTION. ALONG AND
THE LONG TERM CONSIDERATIONS FOR
RESPONSIBLE RESPONSIBLY
DECOMMISSIONING PLATFORMS AND
WELLS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S AN EQUITABLE TRANSITION
FOR THOSE WHO WORK IN THIS
INDUSTRY- TO MOVE INTO. OTHER-
WELL PAYING POSITIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR CONVENING THIS
HEARING TODAY I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT THE CLEAN UP AND RECOVERY
FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY SPELL IS
PROCEEDING WELL AND THE
SITUATION LOOKS A LOT BETTER
THAN IT DID WHEN WE MET IN YOUR
DISTRICT LAST NOVEMBER. I THINK
IF THERE'S ANY SILVER LINING TO
A SPELL IT'S THAT IT SHARPENS
OUR FOCUS ON THE RISKS OF
PETROLEUM DEPENDENCE AND DEMANDS
THAT WE CONSIDER HOW WE WILL
TRANSITION AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS TOWARD A SAFER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY FUTURE. THIS
HEARING WILL FOCUS ON ONE
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THAT
TRANSITION HOW BEST TO MANAGE A
DECLINING RESOURCE AN AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF JOBS AND
REVENUE THAT MUST BE PLAYED.
THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM THAT WILL
SOLVE ITSELF AND THE CLOCK IS
TICKING BOTH ON THE CLIMATE
IMPACTS AND WHEN THE NEXT
ACCIDENT MAY OCCUR. COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ARE AT
RISK DUE TO THE INHERENT RISKS
OF OIL PRODUCTION AND DELIVERY
COMBINED WITH AN AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. OUTDATED
POLLUTION CONTROLS. AND
INADEQUATE MAINTENANCE AS I SAID
IN NOVEMBER THESE RISKS PALE IN
COMPARISON TO THE DAILY HEALTH
IMPACTS OF PETROLEUM PRODUCTION
REFINING AND USE. EVEN IF
ACCIDENTS ARE ELIMINATING USING
OIL AS INTENDED KILLS PEOPLE ON
THE PLANET. AND LOW INCOME AND
MINORITY COMMUNITIES SUFFER THE
MOST I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS
HEARING TODAY. WHAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER AND WHAT ACTIONS THE
STATE MAY NEED TO TAKE TO
FACILITATE DECOMMISSIONING AS
PART OF THE TRANSITION TO A
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY FUTURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FIRST I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR ONE CONVENE
THIS PATTERN BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S A CONVERSATION THAT
ABSOLUTELY- NESS IS NECESSARY TO
HAVE NOT ONLY FOR OUR OWN OUT OF
EDUCATION BUT ALSO FOR THE
RESIDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THIS OIL SPILL I
REPRESENT AN HONOR TO REPRESENT
THE SIXTY FOUR STATE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT- MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COMPTON CARSON WOMAN TO KNOW
LONG BEACH. LITTLE GUARDINO AND
ALSO TOWARDS. IN OCTOBER IN THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES REPORTED THAT
A PIPELINE LEAK ABOUT- A HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR THOUSAND GALLONS.
I'M INTO THE COASTAL WATERS
WHICH CAUSED A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT TO THE BEACH INTO THE
WETLANDS INTO THE ENVIRONMENT.
BECAUSE OF THAT PARTICULARLY
SINCE THE OIL SPILL MY STAFF
HAVE- BEEN ON WEEKLY CONFERENCE
CALLS MONITORING THE SITUATION
ANSWERING CALLS BECAUSE
CERTAINLY- IN ORANGE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE AREA WHERE IT
AFFECTED ITS RAVEL EVEN TO THE
AREAS IN WHICH I REPRESENTS-
AGAIN. I REPRESENT PAR
SUPPORTERS OF LONG BEACH AND
ALSO THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES AND
SO WE'RE IN WE WERE IMPACTED BY
BY THIS AS WELL AS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WHO COMES FROM ORGANIZED
LABOR THE LABOR BACKGROUND I AM
HIGHLY INTERESTED TO HEAR FROM
THE STATE BUILDING SINCE RATES
ON THE WHAT DOES THE
DECOMMISSIONED MEANS TO THE
WORKERS- IN THAT PARTICULAR
AREA. I AM ALSO INTERESTED IN
HEARING FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE CENTERS AND OTHERS ON
STRATEGIES AND HOW DO WE MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD IN ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE MAKING SURE THAT THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN- IN THE NEAR NEAR
FUTURE I'M SPECIFICALLY.
INTERESTED INTO HEARING. IF
THERE IS AY LEGISLATION-
LEGISLATION OR BUDGET
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COMES FROM
TODAY'S DISCUSSIONWILL BE
MEANINGFUL AS WE MOVE FORWARD
LASTLY. I WOULD LIKE TO AGAIN
THANK MY COLLEAGUES- FOR YOUR
DEDICATION AND ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE IS ONE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IT'SONE THAT I
BELIEVE THAT OUR RESIDENTS. IN
THE AFFECTED AREA AND OUTSIDE
THE AFFECTED AREAS ABSOLUTELY
DESERVE TO HAVE IN THIS OPEN
FORUM I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION TO THE PEOPLE DOING
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS TO WEIGHING
IN. ON THEIR CONCERNS BUT MOST
OF ALL LOOKING AT HOW- SOLUTIONS
CAN BE DERIVED AT THE SITUATION
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. THANK YOU- TO
THE CHAIRS FOR CONVENING TODAY'S
HEARING- I REPRESENT COASTAL SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND SO WHEN WE HAVE
THE ORANGE COUNTY OIL SPILL. MY
DISTRICT IS THE FIRST AFFECTED
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY BY ED. AND
HEARINGS LIKE THIS ARE
ESSENTIAL- IF WE EVER WANT TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE ONLY
SOLUTION THAT WILL PREVENT OIL
SPILLS LIKE THIS FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN WHICH IS DE COMMISSIONING.
WE NEED TO PLAN CAREFULLY- NOT
ONLY SO WE CAN SAFELY TACKLE-
THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ENGINEERING CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH PERMANENTLY
SHUTTING DOWN AND CLEANING UP
THESE OPERATIONS IN OUR COASTAL
WATERS. BUT ALSO TO TRANSITION
THE WORK FORCE IN A WAY THAT
LEAVES THEM WITH A VIABLE JOBS
AND CAREERS TO REPLACE THE ONES
BEING LOST. I'M LOOKING FOR TO
THE TESTIMONY TODAY AND LEARNING
HOW WE CAN WORK COLLABORATIVELY
TO CONTINUE ADVANCING POLICIES.
THAT PROTECT OUR STATE'S
PRECIOUS NATURAL RESOURCES LIKE
ACOSTA TOP. INSURANCE PARTNER
FEATURE THAT INCLUDES THE
SKILLED WORKFORCE THAT MEETS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU CHURN UP
BETWEEN ARSON MEMBERS FOR
JOINING US HERE THIS MORNING
ALWAYS ON A VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
AS CHAIR OF THE MARCH MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE. ONE OF MY PRIORITIES
IS TO HELP BETTER PREPARE
CALIFORNIA FOR DISASTERS AND
PREVENT THEM IN THE FIRST PLACE
WE ALL THE CASE. AS IT DOES
PRONE STATE FROM FIRES FLOODS
EARTHQUAKES IN THE OIL SPILLS.
AS WE LOOK TO. DECOMMISSION SOME
OF THESE PROBLEMATIC UP OIL RIGS
MY FIRST. ISSUE I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT HOW WE BETTER PREPARED
THAT AS WE'RE LOOKING TO. REMOVE
SOME OF THESE ARE OR WERE EXTENT
ARE WE IN A GOOD PLACE TO
RESPOND IN CASE ANY OTHER.
SPILLS COME FROM THAT ARE WE
BETTER PREPARE LESSONS LEARNED.
FROM WHAT HAPPENED HERE A FEW
MONTHS AGO THERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OUR FIRST RESPONDERS OUT
THERE THAT RESPOND TO THESE
TYPES OF. DISASTERS ARE HAVE
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO THEIR JOB
TO GET THIS- THE BILLS. CARE OF
AND STOPPED ENTIRELY SO WITHOUT-
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
BEING HERE. AND LOOK FOR TO THIS
HEARING ON DISCUSSIONS ON HOW WE
CAN ALL SHARE OUR SHARED GOALS
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES. THANK VENTURE FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR ALL
OF THE COMMENTS AS WELL AS A
SPEAKER SPEAKING TODAY I JUST I
KNOW THAT WE'RE ALL HERE TO COME
UP WITH COMMONSENSE SOLUTIONS
AND SERVICES HEARING DEALS WITH
POTENTIAL DECOMMISSIONING
OFFSHORE OIL I WANT TO START OFF
WITH A SIMPLE YET OVERLOOKED
POINT EVERY COOPER WE DO NOT
PRODUCE HERE IN CALIFORNIA MEANS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
IMPORT FROM COUNTRIES SUCH AS
CHINA AND SAUDI ARABIA. THESE
ARE COUNTRIES THAT DO NOT HAVE
AB THREE TWO. REGULATIONS DO NOT
HAVE ARE YOUR STANDARDS AND DO
NOT HAVE OR OCEAN WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS. IN A TWIST OF IRONY
AND OFFSHORE OIL BAND ACTUALLY
ENDANGERS OUR ENVIRONMENTAL EVEN
MORE. WITH INCREASED NEEDS FOR
OVERSEAS OIL AS A RESULT OF A
BAND WE WILL SEE INCREASED
TANKERS AND CARGO SHIPS COMING
INTO OUR WATERS AND WE'VE SEEN
OF WHAT HOW THAT HAS HAPPEN.
JUST FOR CONTENT ONE OF THESE
VESSELS CAN CARRY ONE MILLION
GALLONS OF OIL IMAGINE WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF WAITED TANKER
ACCIDENT FOR SHORTS. IT WOULD
TAKE DECADES TO RECOVER FROM
CATASTROPHIC LIKE THIS. LASTLY I
LEAVE MY OPINION REMARKS
REMAINING COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLY MULTIPLE
AIR TOXIC EXPOSURE STUDIES FROM
THE S. C. A. Q. M. DEEP THE AIR
TOXIC CANCER RISK IS HIGHER THAN
NINETY NINE PERCENT. OF THE
POPULATION FOR COMMUNITIES
LIVING NEAR PORTS AND DIESEL
PARTICLE MATTER IS MADE UP OF
SIXTY SEVEN POINT 4% OF THE
POLLUTANTS CONTRIBUTE TO A
CANCER RISK SO AS WE SIT HERE
TODAY LISTENING TO POTENTIAL
DECOMMISSIONING OF OFFSHORE OIL
I AM AS THAT WEAKNESS THAT THIS
POLICY MAY BE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND RAMIFICATIONS.
AGAIN I JUST I'M I'M TO THIS I
THINK THAT WE'VE ALL GOT- GOOD
IDEAS I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WHATEVER WE DO WON'T HAVE
RAMIFICATIONS- THAT WILL LAST
LONGER THAN WITH NO OIL SPILL
COULD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND THE STAFF FOR
HOSTING THE OUR SECOND MEETING-
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT
WAS THE ONE THAT GOT DIRECTLY
IMPACTED. WITH THE OIL SPILL AND
OUR BEACHES WAS SHUT DOWN. AND
MY GOAL HAS ALWAYS BEEN IS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS TYPE OF VET WOULD NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN I KNOW COSTA LINE.
AS YOU KNOW I WAS ON THE SCENE
DO AERIAL TOURS LAND TOURS BEACH
TORE. MEETING WITH STAFF COMMAND
CENTER WEEKLY MEETINGS MYSELF
AND ALL MY STAFF- YOU NAME IT
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND NOT JUST
WHAT THE DISCUSSION IS TODAY. WE
HAD ISSUES WITH THE COMMAND
CENTER BEEN AND I'D TELL YOU
THAT'S NOT EVEN NEAR ORANGE
COUNTY. THAT IF YOU WERE TO TAKE
YOU KNOW IF YOU WERE FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES OFFICE
GOING ALL THE WAY TO THE COMMAND
CENTER IT COULD EASILY TAKE AN
HOUR TO AN HOUR AND A HALF- WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES WE
NEED COMMAND CENTERS. IN AREAS
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED NOT SO
FAR AWAY. WE NEED. TO TALK ABOUT
NOTIFICATION. WHEN THEY WORK WHY
WOULD THEY DELAY. ALL THESE WERE
DISCUSS. AND I HOPE THAT WE
CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS. SO
THAT WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE
DON'T JUST. PINPOINT ONE ISSUE
IS THAT THIS HAS TO BE AN
OVERALL. WE NEED TO ALSO HELP
AND ENCOURAGE CITIES ON THE
COAST LINE. TO HAVE A MASTER
PLAN. AND IN A COORDINATED
MASTER PLAN. THAT WORKS TOGETHER
ANY COORDINATION WITH EACH OTHER
SINCE THEIR NEXT DOOR TO EACH
OTHER. BECAUSE WHAT WE FOUND.
DURING THIS. IT DURING THIS TIME
WAS THAT. SOME CITIES HADN'T AT
THE CITY'S DIDN'T SOME SET CITY
WHERE EXTREMELY COMPREHENSIVE.
OTHERS WOULD JUST. OKAY SO I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW. AS A STATE
AID AS A STATE WE SHOULD LOOK AT
AND HELP THE CITY'S- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE HAVE SAME. MASTER PLAN OR
SIMILAR MASTER PLAN. THAT THE
COORDINATION WOULD BE VERY VERY
SMOOTH. SO AND AS WE CONTINUE ON
OUR MEETINGS. I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC. AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS
EVERYONE OF AFFECTED BY IT.
BECAUSE I WOULD TELL YOU
INTERESTING FACT THAT OUR- LOCAL
ECONOMY. WHEN THIS HAPPENED WE
HAD OUR LARGEST AIR SHOW PACIFIC
AIR SHOW THAT WAS SHUT DOWN A
DAY EARLY. AND WE'RE THAT WE CAN
WAS EXPECTED BE OVER A MILLION
PEOPLE. AND THEY WERE SHUT DOWN
. AND ALL OVER BUSINESSES WHO
ESPECIALLY OUR RESTAURANTS
BIETEN SO MUCH FOOD THAT ENDED
UP BEING THROWN OUT BECAUSE
THERE WAS NOBODY LEFT ON THE
BEACH- BECAUSE THEY WERE
ANTICIPATED OVER MILLION PEOPLE
VISITING THE AREA. SO THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
SO IT'S NOT JUST YOU KNOW THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF WE NEED LOOK AT
THE EMPLOYEES WE NEED THE LOOK
AT THEM- THE LOCAL ECONOMY THE
BUSINESSES WITHIN THE AREA AS
WELL AND HOW IT'S AFFECTED AND
OF COURSE THE NEIGHBORHOODS. AND
LIKE IT'S NOT ONLY IT'S JUST NOT
ONLY BUSINESS THAT'S RIGHT NEXT
TO THE BEACH. THIS IS WITH IN
THAT CITY OR NEXT DOOR TO THAT
CITY BECAUSE THEY DO BENEFIT
FROM THE TOURISM. THAT COMES
INTO THAT AREA IS SO IT'S JUST
NOT ONLY THE SEAS. ALONG THE
COASTS IT'S ALSO CITIES NEXT
DOOR TO THEM AS WELL. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU MANAGER FOR- HOSTING
THE SECOND MEETING AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION AND
DISCUSSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRAND. MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THIS JOINT COMMITTEE
THANK YOU TO THE OTHER JURORS
HAVE JOINED US THIS MORNING THIS
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND IT'S NOT JUST IN THE
COASTLINE- IN MY DISTRICT I
REPRESENT THE LARGEST URBAN OIL
FIELD IN THE COUNTRY WE HAD A
SIXTEEN HUNDRED GALLON OIL SPILL
JUST LAST APRIL SO THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE TRANSITION. OUT OF
OUR FOSSIL FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE
INTO A GREEN ECONOMY AND MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A JUST
TRANSITION FOR ALL OF THOSE
WORKERS WHO DESERVE AT AT AN
EQUAL WAGE WERE STRONGER WAGE IN
JUST AS MANY JOBS AS CURRENTLY
THAT CURRENTLY EXIST AND OUR
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY. IS
IMPORTANT BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT HERE FROM ALL OF THE
STAKE HOLDERS WHO ARE IMPACTED
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER THE
BUSINESSES LOCAL RESIDENTS-
WORKERS. AND REMEMBER THAT A LOT
OF YOUNG FOLKS OF LOWER LIFE
EXPECTANCIES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
POOR AIR QUALITY POOR WATER
QUALITY AND OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS THAT THEY LIVE CLOSE TO
SO. THANK YOU FOR CONVENING THIS
PANEL OF EXPERTS TODAY I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO LEARNING AND
THINKING AND I'M HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN ANY LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTIONS WITH THIS BODY COMES
UP WITH. FOR THE SAKE. THANK YOU
I WITH THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
JUMP INTO OUR FIRST PANEL. MY
APOLOGIES ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT ON
HOLD AND I'LL BE QUICK BECAUSE A
LOT OF INSIDE A LISTEN I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT- YEAH I MY
DISTRICT IS HAS THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH AND THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES I AM THE REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THOSE. THOSE TWO PORTS IS A
LOT OF OIL MOVEMENT THERE A LOT
OF OIL PRODUCTION THERE SO I'M
VERY INTERESTED IN THE
CONVERSATION TODAY TO ME THE
SOLUTION PROBABLY LIES. IN SOME%
TYPE OF STATEWIDE RESERVE FUND
BECAUSE REMEMBER THE STATE IS A
PARTNER IN MANY THESE OPERATIONS
THE STATE MAKES MONEY OFFICE OR
HOME THAT IS HOW WE PAY IN PART
FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND OTHER
FUNCTIONS OF THE STATE. SO THOSE
ARE CONVERSATION TOPICS WE NEED
TO INCLUDE AS WELL SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I AND WITH
THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND-
WELCOME OUR FIRST PANELISTS AT
JENNIFER LEE CASEY. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION- THE FIRST PANEL.
WILL FOCUS ON THE HISTORY OF
OFFSHORE DRILLING AND PLATFORM
JUST DECOMMISSIONING. IN
CALIFORNIA WATERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CASEY. THANK YOU
RIGHT GOOD MORNING TEARS
PETRIE-NORRIS THREE OF US IN
BLOOM AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JENNIFER LOOK HAS THE
HIGH END THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
DISCUSSION TODAY. THE STATE'S
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS LEASING
HISTORY IS COMPLEX AND NUANCED.
AND TO STATE THE OBVIOUS THE
ENERGY POLICIES FROM THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES ARE VERY
DIFFERENT FROM CALIFORNIA'S
VALUES AND PRINCIPLES. AND OUR
POLICY PRIORITIES OF TODAY.
HOWEVER THESE LEGACY DECADES OLD
ENERGY POLICIES ARE WHAT CREATED
THE LEGAL CONSTITUTIONAL AND
CONTRACTUAL FRAMEWORK. THAT
DICTATES THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
OIL AND GAS LEASE MANAGEMENT
FRAMEWORK TO THIS DAY AND WILL
NECESSARILY INFORM YOUR
DISCUSSION AND DELIBERATION. ON
HOW TO ADVANCE OUR SHARED ENERGY
CLEAN ENERGY AND JUST TRANSITION
OBJECTIVES. IT IS COMPLEX BUT
NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO ADDRESS NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. FIRST AS
BACKGROUND THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION MANAGES THE STATE SAW
FROM PUBLIC TRUST LANDS WHICH
INCLUDE APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
TWENTY RIVERS AND SLEW'S. FORTY
LAKES AND LANDS ALONG THE OVER
ELEVEN HUNDRED MILES. OF
COASTLINE AND UNDERLINE THE
PACIFIC OCEAN OUT THREE MILES TO
THE STATE FEDERAL BOUNDARY. THE
COMMISSION ALSO EXERCISES
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY OVER THE
STATE'S PUBLIC LANDS GRANTED IN
TRUST BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
APPROXIMATELY. SEVENTY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT THIS INCLUDES
OFFSHORE LONG BEACH OIL
OPERATIONS OPERATED AND MANAGED
BY THE CITY OF LONG BEACH. WELL
THE COMMISSION HAS SOME
REGULATORY FUNCTIONS IT IS
PRINCIPALLY A LAND AND RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT AGENCY NOT A
REGULATORY AGENCY. THE
COMMISSION IS SIMILAR TO THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF OCEAN AND
ENERGY MANAGEMENT OR BOEM. AND
THE BUREAU OF SAFETY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ENFORCEMENT BESSIE
OFFSHORE AND THE BUREAU OF LAND
MANAGEMENT ON SHORE. FOR THOSE
OIL AND GAS OFFSHORE FACILITIES
AND PIPELINES LOCATED
EXCLUSIVELY IN STATE WATERS THE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURES MANAGE
PURSUANT TO A LEASE FROM THE
COMMISSION OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GRANT T. SPECIFICALLY PIPELINES
THAT ARE LOCATED SOLELY WITHIN
STATE BOUNDARIES INCLUDING STATE
WATERS ARE CALLED INTRASTATE
PIPELINES AND THEY ARE REGULATED
BY THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL. FOR
THOSE PIPELINES THAT CROSS STATE
WATERS CONNECTING FEDERAL
OFFSHORE PLATFORMS TO ON SHORE
FACILITIES. THESE PIPELINES ARE
CONSIDERED INTERSTATE PIPELINES
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THROUGH THE PIPELINE AND
HAZARDOUS MAERIALS SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION ARE FILMS THAT
HAS PRIMARY REGULATORY AUTHORITY
. THE COMMISSION FIRE MARSHAL
CAL GEM FILMS THAT AND BESSIE
ALL COLLABORATIVELY WORK
TOGETHER TO SHARE INSPECTION
REPORTS AND ANALYSIS AND
COMPLIANCE PURSUANT TO AN MLA.
THE M. O. A. ASSURE IS A
COORDINATED ANALYTICAL FRAMEWORK
FOR REGULATION IMPLEMENTATION
AND COMPLIANCE. FOR OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION FACILITIES LIKE
PLATFORMS ARE ISLAND IN FEDERAL
WATERS THOSE ARE BY BASS. IN
STATE WATERS ARE A MANAGE PURSE
TO A FOR THE- OR TO GRANT- FROM
THE LA. LIKE THE LONG BEACH
OPERATIONS. I KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF INTEREST IN WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH FEDERAL OPERATIONS- I'M NOT
AN EXPERT ON FEDERAL OPERATIONS
BUT WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
THERE ARE TWENTY THREE PLATFORMS
IN FEDERAL WATERS ALL BUILT
BETWEEN NINETEEN SIXTY AND
NINETEEN NINETIES. AND THIRTY
EIGHT EXISTING FEDERAL LEASES
ALL LOCATED BETWEEN THREE POINT
SEVEN MILES AND TEN POINT FIVE
MILES OFFSHORE IN WATER DEPTHS
BETWEEN NINETY FIVE FEET. AND
TWELVE HUNDRED FEET- THIRTEEN
FEDERAL PLATFORMS OFFSHORE SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. FOR FEDERAL
PLATFORMS OFFSHORE VENTURA
COUNTY. AND FOR FEDERAL
PLATFORMS OFFSHORE LOS ANGELES
AND ORANGE COUNTY. EIGHT ARE NO
LONGER PRODUCING THEY'RE ALL
LOCATED IN THE SANTA BARBARA
CHANNEL AND BESSIE WITH THE
ASSISTANCE FROM BOMB ARE
DEVELOPING A PROGRAMMATIC EIS TO
INFORM FUTURE DECOMMISSIONING
APPLICATIONS. THE DRAFT
PROGRAMMATIC EIS IS ANTICIPATED
BE RELEASED IN FEBRUARY WITH A
FINAL RELEASED IN JUNE NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. SO TAKING A STEP
BACK AND LOOKING SPECIFICALLY AT
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE THE LEGISLATURE CREATED THE
FIRST THAILAND'S OIL AND GAS
LEASING PROGRAM. THE EXISTING
OFFSHORE LEASES AND THE
COMMISSION IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING WERE ISSUED OVER A
THIRTY YEAR PERIOD BETWEEN
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT AND
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. AND
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
CUNNINGHAM SHALL ACT WHICH
SERVES AS THE FOUNDATIONAL LAW
FOR THE EXISTING OIL AND GAS
LEASES THE COMMISSION CURRENTLY
MANAGES. CERTAINLY THIS AFTER
CARD THE COMMISSION TO ISSUE OIL
AND GAS LEASES FOR A TERM NOT
BASED ON YEARS. BUT FOR SO LONG
AS OIL AND GAS IS PRODUCED IN
PAYING QUANTITIES. ESSENTIALLY
THIS MEANS THAT A LESSEE OR AN
OPERATOR CAN PRODUCE OIL AND GAS
PURSUANT TO THEIR STATELY
INDEFINITELY. AS LONG AS IT IS
ECONOMIC FOR THEM TO DO SO. THIS
SPECIFIC TERM IS INCLUDED IN ALL
THE REMAINING ELEVEN ACTIVELY
PRODUCING OFFSHORE LEASES THE
COMMISSION MANAGES. THESE LEASES
WERE ENTERED INTO OVER FIFTY
YEARS AGO AND PRIOR TO THE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR COASTAL
SANCTUARY ACT. THROUGH THE
COASTAL SANCTUARY ACT THE
LEGISLATURE PLACE THE ENTIRETY
OF CALIFORNIA'S COAST OFF LIMITS
TO NEW OIL AND GAS LEASES. AS
YOU PREVIOUSLY HEARD LUMBERKINGS
EASTERN OIL SPILL PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE ACTORS PASSED IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE THIS THAT
GAVE THE COMMISSION ADDITIONAL
TOOLS TO PREVENT OIL SPILLS AT
THE STATE'S OFFSHORE PLATFORMS
AND ISLANDS THREE MONTHLY AND
ANNUAL INSPECTIONS. AND
COMPREHENSIVE SAFETY AUDITS
CONDUCTED ON ALL OUT OFFSHORE
PLATFORMS AND ISLANDS EVERY FIVE
YEARS. MORE RECENTLY THERE BEEN
A NUMBER OF LAWS PASSED THAT
PROHIBIT THE COMMISSION. FROM
ISSUING LEASES FOR NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE PIPELINES
THAT WOULD FACILITATE NEW OIL
AND GAS DEVELOPMENT IN FEDERAL
WATERS AND ON FEDERALLY
PROTECTED LAND IN CALIFORNIA.
CERTAINLY THERE'S ALSO BEEN A
NUMBER OF LAWS PASSED THAT HAVE
ADDED TOOLS TO THE COMMISSION'S
TOOLBOX TO BETTER MANAGE AND
REGULATE EXISTING. STATE OIL AND
GAS OPERATIONS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROTECT THE
STATE FROM LIABILITY. NOW TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
EXISTING OFFSHORE OPEN
OPERATIONS NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO
THIS SHOWS THE LONG BEACH
OPERATIONS- THE WILMINGTON FIELD
OFFICER LONG BEACH IS THE FOURTH
LARGEST OIL FIELD IN NORTH
AMERICA THROUGH A SERIES OF
STATUTES AND AGREEMENTS THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH IS CONSIDERED THE
OPERATOR. AND CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES CORPORATION IS THE
CITY'S CONTRACTOR AND THE STATE
RECEIVES A SIGNIFICANT SHARE OF
NET PROFITS GENERATED AT THE
LONG BEACH UNIT THE FOR OIL
ISLANDS AND THE WEST WOMAN
OPERATIONS PRIMARY LOCATED UNDER
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH. AS THIS
OPERATION IS NOT MANAGE FOR A
TYPICAL LESSOR LESSEE
RELATIONSHIP THE COMMISSION VERY
LIMITED AUTHORITY OVER THE
MANAGEMENT OF THESE OPERATIONS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. HOWEVER BASED
ON A SERIES OF STATUTES AND
AGREEMENTS THE STATE IS LIABLE
FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PLUGGING AND
ABANDONMENT OF THE WELLS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE WILMINGTON
OPERATION. BY STATUTE THE STATE
HAS SET ASIDE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS PROGRAM
THIS LEAVES APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES. THE ESTIMATES TO
CUT COMPLETELY PLUG AND ABANDON
THE HUNDREDS OF WELLS IS OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
YOU CAN SEE ON THIS SLIDE THE
REVENUE- GENERATED- TO THE STATE
FROM THESE OPERATE. AS WELL AS
THE WELL COUNTY AND THE FIELD
LIFE AS ESTIMATED BY C. R. C.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. I'M NOT GOING
TO SHARE AND MATRIX FIRST AND
THEN A COUPLE OF MAPS TO HELP
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CONTEXT OF
THE OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS LEASES
THE COMMISSION MANAGES. SO THESE
ARE THE ELEVEN ACTIVELY
PRODUCING LEASES- ORGANIZED BY-
AREA SANTA BARBARA I'LL SERVE
INTERACT ON TO LA IN ORANGE
COUNTY. ALONG WITH THEIR WELL
COUNT LIABILITY PROTECTION AND A
FISCALLY THE LAST FISCAL YEAR IS
REVENUE AND GENERATION. AND
SANTA BARBARA CHANNEL WE- THE
COMMISSION MANAGES TO OFFSHORE
LEASES THOSE WELLS ARE DRILLED
FROM ONSHORE AND GO OFF INTO THE
OFFSHORE RESERVOIRS. WE HAVE
EIGHT ACTIVE PIPELINE LEASES
CONNECTING FEDERAL PLATFORMS
ONSHORE PROCESSING FACILITIES
AND THEN- NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THIS IS THE SANTA BARBARA
CHANNEL- THE FEDERAL PLATFORM
SUBJECT TO THE DECOMMISSIONING
PROGRAMMATIC EIS THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER OUR HARVEST
HERMOSA HILL DOGO HABITAT HOW
CHEN HOGAN GRACE AND GAIL. IN
ORANGE COUNTY NEXT SLIDE PLEASE
AS WE MOVE DOWN THE COAST. WE
HAVE- AT ONE LEAST ASSOCIATE
WITH THE ISLAND SHAFEE. ONE
LEASE ASSOCIATE WITH PLATFORM
AFTER PLATFORM ESTHER'S OPERATED
BY DE CORPS. WE HAVE FIVE LEASES
ASSOCIATED WITH PLATFORM AND ME
PLATFORM AMAZON BY C. R. C. TO
LEASES ASSOCIATE WITH PLATFORM
EVER. HAVE A IS- OPERATED BY DE
CORPS WE HAVE TWO ACTIVE
PIPELINE LEASES CONNECTING
FEDERAL PLATFORMS ONSHORE
PROCESSING FACILITIES AND THAT
INCLUDES THE ORANGE COUNTY OIL
SPILL- PIPELINE CLASS- FROM
ALLEY AND WE HAVE THREE ACTIVE
PIPELINE LEASES CONNECTING AFTER
EVEN ME TO ENTRE. FACILITIES. SO
AS PART OF THESE OIL AND GAS
LEASES AND THE PIPE PLAINLY SAYS
THE COMMISSION REQUIRES THE
OPERATORS TO PAY FOR YOUR MARKET
RENTS AND ROYALTIES. MAINTAIN
BONDS INSURANCE AND OTHER
LIABILITY PROTECTION INSTRUMENTS
TO PROTECT THE STATE. AND AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE COASTAL
SANCTUARY ACT PROHIBITS THE
COMMISSION FROM ISSUING NEW OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION LEASES. THAT
POLICY HAS SET THE FOUNDATION
FOR THE WHERE THE COMMISSION
FINDS ITSELF TODAY PRIORITIZING
AND LEADING THE STATE IN THE
DECOMMISSIONING PHASE OF MANY OF
THE STATE'S OFFSHORE FACILITIES
. AND THAT LEADS ME TO MY FINAL
PART OF MY PRESENTATION. THE
COMMISSION RECOGNIZES THAT THE
EFFECTS AND S. ASSOCIATE WITH
THE CLIMATE CRISIS REQUIRE THE
STATE TO DRAMATICALLY CHANGE THE
WAY IT PRODUCES AND CONSUMES
ENERGY. AND THAT THERE IS A
BRIDGE TO THE SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE. THE COMMISSION IS
COMMITTED TO DOING ITS PART IN
BUILDING THAT BRIDGE AS A
LANDOWNING AGENCY THAT OVERSEES
THE MANAGEMENT OF FOUR MILLION
ACRES OF PUBLIC LANDS. WE ARE
DIDN'T WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
DIVERSIFIER LEASING AND REVENUE
GENERATING PORTFOLIO. AND
POSITION OURSELVES TO BE
PARTNERS IN FACILITATING OUR
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. THIS
INCLUDES PURSUING PARALLEL
TRACKS OF FACILITATING
GEOTHERMAL SOLAR AND WIND
DEVELOPMENT. WHILE ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS
AND OUR LESSEES TO ABANDON IDLE
WELLS HELLO AT HEAD AND CAL GEMS
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS. AND
SURE THE STATE IS ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED THROUGH BONDS SINKING
FUNDS PROPERTY LIENS AND OTHER
MECHANISMS. DECOMMISSIONING
OFFSHORE FACILITIES LIKE A
PLATFORM HOLLY AND RINCON ISLAND
. WE MEDIAN REMEDIATING OFFSHORE
ORPHAN LEGACY WELLS AND
IMPLEMENTING ROBUST AND
COMPREHENSIVE SPILL PREVENTION
INSPECTION PROGRAMS. IN FACT IN
THE LAST SIX YEARS THE
COMMISSION HAS FACILITATED THE
TERMINATION OF TEN OFFSHORE OIL
AND GAS LEASES RETURNING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND ACRES OF THE
COASTAL SANCTUARY. AND IN
CONCLUSION THE COMMISSION
UNDERSTANDS ITS PLACE BOTH IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND ITS
FUTURE. OF FOSSIL FUEL SUPPLY
AND DEMAND DEPENDENCY. THE
COMMISSION IS COMMITTED TO A
JUST TRANSITION WHILE
RESPONSIBLY MANAGING THE STATE'S
EXISTING OIL AND GAS LEASES.
CONSISTENT WITH THE LAW AND
ENSURING THE STATE IS PROTECTED
FROM LIABILITY ASSOCIATED WITH
pOPERATIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THAT AT
FOR THAT REALLY COMPREHENSIVE
OVERVIEW. AND I KNOW YOU WILL BE
JOINING US- ON A COUPLE OF OUR
OTHER PANELS INCLUDING THE NEXT
PANEL WHICH- IS FOCUSED. AROUND
TO AT IT KIND OF DEEPER DIVE
INTO COST LIABILITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS ASSOCIATED
WITH DECOMMISSIONING. I DO JUST
HAVE ONE CLARIFYING QUESTION SO.
THAT WOULD MAKE SURE THAT I
UNDERSTOOD CORRECTLY SO I. DID
YOU SAY THAT THE STATE HAS THE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
PLUGIN AND ABANDONMENT- FOR. THE
AT LONG BEACH AND WEST
WILMINGTON. FIELDS YES OKAY AND
THAT THERE IS CURRENTLY A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ANTICIPATED UNFUNDED LIABILITY
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT YEAH OKAY
ALL RIGHT. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS BEFORE YOU AT THE
NUMBER OF YES- THIS WITH REGARD
TO THOSE OIL FIELDS YOU MATCH.
IN LONG BEACH YESTERDAY PROBABLY
WHO I MET IN EVERYBODY HERE
VOTED I DON'T KNOW THE VOTE
COUNT BUT YOU VOTED FOR A BILL
TO INCREASE THAT CAP BECAUSE THE
THRESHOLD I WAS TOO LOW TO
ULTIMATELY- YOU KNOW. TAKE TO OF
WHEN THOSE WHEN THOSE WELLS ARE
ABANDONED TO. TO CLOSE THEM
BECAUSE WHEN YOU KNOW WHAT IT
WAS A BAD IT'S A COMPLEX PROCESS
OBVIOUSLY PUT A CAP ON THE
WALKWAY DOWN ON A- MUCH MUCH
MORE COMPLEX. TO PROPERLY
ABANDON A WELL THERE'S COMPANIES
THAT JUST HANDLE ABANDONED WELLS
IT'S A REAL PROCESS. SO- BUT
AGAIN YESTERDAY WE DID HAVE A
BILL BELIEVES AB THREE FIVE
THREE IF I'M CORRECT. GO THROUGH
OF THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR- WITHOUT A
OPPOSITION IF I RECALL CORRECTLY
TO THE SUPPORT INCREASING THAT
CAPSULE ULTIMATELY WE CANNOT
CLOSE AS WELL AS AN APPROPRIATE
FASHION WHEN THE TIME COMES. YES
THANK YOU. IF UP SORRY I WAS
JUST GOING TO ADD. ON TO THAT
STATE HAS RECEIVED AND CONTINUES
TO RECEIVE A SIGNIFICANT SHARE
OF THE REVENUE THAT'S GENERATED.
THE NET PROFITS THAT ARE
GENERATED AT THE LONG BEACH
OPERATIONS WHICH IS WHY PURSUANT
TO. VARIOUS STATUTES AND
AGREEMENTS THE STATE IS ALSO
LIABLE FOR PLUGGING AND
ABANDONING THE WELLS AT THE- END
OF THE ECONOMIC LIFE OF THOSE
FIELDS. AND SO. THAT LEGISLATURE
CREATED THIS OIL TRUST FUND
WHERE TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
REVENUE THE STATE RECEIVES EVERY
MONTH WOULD GO INTO THIS.
ABANDONMENT FUND BUT IT WAS
CAPPED AT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. SO WE- WILL NEED TO BE
LEGISLATION TO INCREASE THAT
CAP. YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT
THANK YOU AND SPEAKING OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF- DEALING WITH
THESE SITUATIONS AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- TESTIMONY-
IT. HOW IS IT DETERMINED. WHAT
EXACTLY IS PART OF THE
DECOMMISSIONING- OF A OF A WELL
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT WHAT WE ALL
ARE FAMILIAR WITH ITS ABOVE
WATER BUT THERE'S A HECK OF A
LOT THAT'S BELOW IN THIS
PIPELINE SEN. AND WHAT NOT SO
HOW HOW IS THAT DETERMINED YEAH
SO- THE WAY I LIKE TO LOOK AT-
THE- AND DECOMMISSIONING OF
ENTIRE FACILITY YOU HAVE THE
PLATFORM'S YOU HAVE THE WELLS
THAT ARE SUB SURFACE GOING VERY
DEEP INTO BELOW THE OCEAN FLOOR.
YOU HAVE VARIOUS PIPELINES- THAT
TRANSPORT OIL WATER GAS AND ALSO
POWER CABLES. THE FIRST STEP IN
DECOMMISSIONING IS TO PLUG AND
ABANDON THE WELLS SO THAT THERE
IS NO MORE RISK OF ANY KIND OF
RE PRESSURIZATION OR OIL SPILL
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE THAT'S THE
STAGE WE'RE IN A PLATFORM HOLLY.
AND SO YOU GO IN YOU PLUG AND
ABANDON EACH WELL- AT AT AND YOU
HAVE A PROGRAM PLAN FOR EACH OF
THOSE WELLS THAT. ARE DEVELOPED-
BY THE OPERATOR WITH
CONSULTATION FROM THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION AND CAL JAM AND
CAL CHEN HAS TO APPROVE THOSE
WELL. ABANDONMENT PROGRAMS. I
ALL THE WELLS ARE PLUGGED. AND
COMPLETELY PLUGGED AND
ABANDONED- TO THE REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS THERE'S A VERY
LIMITED- AT. RISK FOR AN OIL
SPILL. AT THAT POINT- WE WILL
WHETHER IT'S THE STATE
CONDUCTING IT OR THE OPERATOR-
CONDUCT A FEASIBILITY STUDY
ABOUT WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE.
TO REMOVE THE PLATFORM AND THE
ASSOCIATED INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
AT LEAST WITH PLATFORMS THERE
COULD BE FULL REMOVABLE PARTIAL
REMOVAL OR KEEPING IT ALL IN
PLACE AND SO ALL OF THAT IS
EVALUATED. AND THEN BASED ON
THAT FEASIBILITY STUDY WE
CONDUCTED THE SEQUIN ALICE'S
WHICH IS- NOW TYPICALLY ANY IR.
PRIOR DECOMMISSIONING EFFORTS
LIKE FOR THE CHEVRON- FOR HM-
FOR EACH PLATFORMS. THAT WERE-
THAT DECOMMISSIONED IN THE MID
NINETEEN NINETIES AND ALSO THE
BELMONT ISLAND- PLATFORM
OFFSHORE LONG BEACH IN THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS THOSE ARE ALL
ACTUALLY ANALYZED UNDER A
MITIGATED NEGATIVE NEGATIVE
DECLARATION PURSUANT TO SEE WHAT
BUT NOW WE DO ER'S. AND THEN
FROM THERE- THE COMMISSION STATE
LANDS COMMISSION MAKES THE
DETERMINATION ON. THE EXTENT OF
DECOMMISSIONING AND REMOVAL SO-
THEY CAN DECIDE- AT AT A
PROPERLY NOTICED PUBLIC MEETING
FOR FULL PLATFORM INFRASTRUCTURE
REMOVAL OR SOMETHING- LESS THAN
THAT DEPENDING ON. THE BENEFITS
AND RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH AND IS
THAT A- IF YOU WILL A CRITERIA
BASED DECISION- ARE THEIR
CRITERIA IN THE LAW OR-
REGULATIONS. THAT GUIDE THAT
DECISION MAKING OR MANDATE
CERTAIN DIRECTIONS IN THE
DECISION MAKING I'M NOT
SPECIFICALLY NOT TO KIND OF US
US US. A DIRECT CRITERIA OR
CONDITIONS- THE COMMISSION IS
INFORMED BY THE SEQUIN ALICE'S.
AND ALSO WHAT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE STATE EIGHT.
AND SO THEY HEAR- COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ENVIRONMENTALISTS
EXPERTS- OBVIOUSLY ALL OF OUR
LOCAL AND STATE AND FEDERAL
RESOURCE AGENCY PARTNERS TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE BEST COURSE
OF ACTION IS IN TERMS OF
REMOVAL. AND DECOMMISSIONING. AS
FOR BRYANT. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION- YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT POTENTIALLY
NEEDING TO RAISE THE CAP IN THE
STATE'S LIABILITY I THINK ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK ALSO
POINTING OUT THAT THE STATE
MAKES MONEY ON THIS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MILLION A MONTH TO
GO TOWARDS OF PLUGGING THESE
WELLS I THINK IT'S GOOD POLICY I
AM CURIOUS THOUGH STATUTORILY
ARE THERE ANY REQUIREMENTS ON
THE COMPANIES THAT ARE ALSO
REAPING. I JOIN NORMA'S PROFITS
FROM THIS WORK TO PUT INTO
MILLION A MONTH OR ANY KIND OF
MONEY INTO THE PLUGIN WHERE IS
THIS ONLY THE STATE'S BURDEN AT
THIS CURRENT TIME SO THAT STATE
IS- PRIMARILY LIABLE FOR THAT
PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT OF
WELLS ASSOCIATED WITH THE LONG
BEACH OPERATIONS ONLY THAT IS A
VERY UNIQUE SITUATION- THAT IS
REALLY DICTATED BY A NUMBER OF
STATUTES AND AGREEMENTS THE
STATE ENTERED INTO WELL OVER-
FORTY FIFTY YEARS AGO- FOR THE
REST OF THE OPERATIONS THAT ARE
AND OPERATED UNDER A TYPICAL
LESS OR LESS. RELATIONSHIP FOR
THE STATE THROUGH THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION AS THE LESSOR
AN THE OPERATOR IS A LESSEE
PURSUANT TO THOSE LEASES THE
LAST SEATS AND THE OPERATORS ARE
REQUIRED TO RESTORE THE LEAST
PROMISES TO THEIR NATURAL
CONDITIONS SO THAT WOULD MEAN
THE STANDARD IS FULL REMOVAL AND
FULL PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT OF
ALL THE WELLS AND THAT IS. THAT
THE COST OF THE OPERATOR. SO AT
THIS TIME IT GOING TO GO AHEAD.
WELCOME SOME ADDITIONAL
PANELISTS FOR PANEL TO. MISLI
HAS HE WILL BE PARTICIPATING IN
PENALTIES WE CAN ASK ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS JUST WHERE. THAT SUIT
WITH THAT- WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND WELCOME LINDA CROP
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
CENTER AND DEMAND ECONOMY AND
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND- HOT PANEL TO IS
GOING TO ADD DIVE INTO. ISSUES
AROUND DECOMMISSIONING COST
LIABILITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. UP WITH THAT WELCOME
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US. I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND ADD BEGIN WITH MISS
CROP. WE'VE GOT IF YOU THREE.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING- I'M
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
HEARING AND WANT TO THANK EACH
YEAR AND ALL THE MEMBERS- FROM
THE PREPARATION THAT WENT INTO
PROVIDING THIS OVERVIEW TODAY-
I'M LINDA KROP I AM THE CHIEF
COUNSEL OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE CENTER WHICH IS A PUBLIC
INTEREST ENVIRONMENTAL LAW FIRM
HEADQUARTERED IN SANTA BARBARA
WE WERE FOUNDED AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THE NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE. OIL SPILL- WE ALSO- LIVE
AND WORK RIGHT NEAR THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN PLAINS PIPELINE OIL
SPILL SO I CAN DEFINITELY
EMPATHIZE WITH WHAT- BROKE DOWN
IN ORANGE COUNTY HAVE BEEN GOING
THROUGH- WE ALSO REPRESENT THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION REGARDING
BE. SEVERAL UPCOMING
PROGRAMMATIC ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT STATEMENT THAT I'LL TALK
ABOUT BRIEFLY- WHEN A LEAD OFF
BY SAYING THAT WE ARE IN THE-
VERY EXCITING MOMENT FOR THOSE
WHO DO WANT TO SEE THE PHASE OUT
OF OFFSHORE OIL. AND A
DISPOSITION OF THE PLATFORMS- WE
ARE TURNING THE PAGE FROM OIL
DEVELOPMENT TO PLATFORM TO
COMMISSIONING. THANK WE HOPE
THIS HEARING WILL EDUCATE
LEGISLATORS AND THE PUBLIC
REGARDING THE STATE'S EXISTING
LAW PERTAINING TO
DECOMMISSIONING OF COURAGE
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
CURRENT. ENVIRONMENTAL AGENCY
REVIEW PROCESSES AND I'M
WONDERING IF- JENNIFER CAN PUT
THE- MY SLIDE SHOW UP. THE POWER
POINT. GREAT THANK YOU OUR NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. SO THERE ARE
TWENTY SEVEN PLATFORMS OFF THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA EIGHT ARE
PERMANENTLY SHUT DOWN IN THE
DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS UP
PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT IS
UNDER WAY PRIMARILY EMPLOYING
FOR WORKERS. WHEN THESE
PLATFORMS WERE INSTALLED THE OIL
COMPANIES WERE REQUIRED TO
REMOVE ALL STRUCTURES WHEN
PRODUCTION CEASED AND RESTORE
THE MARINE ENVIRONMENT TO ITS
NATURAL CONDITION. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. THERE ARE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR CONGRESS PASSED THE
NATIONAL FISHING AND HANDSOME
ACTOR PROMOTE ARTIFICIAL REEFS.
ENACTMENT OF THIS LAW WAS
FOLLOWED BY REGULATIONS ALLOWING
AN EXCEPTION TO THE REQUIREMENT
THAT OFFER PLATFORMS MUST BE
FULLY REMOVED AND DISPOSEDI'M
SURE. THAT REGULATIONS ALLOW
PLATFORMS TO BE USED IN THE
CREATION OF AN ARTIFICIAL REEF
PURSUANT TO A NATIONAL ROOF PLAN
APPROVED BY KNOW WHAT.
SUBSEQUENTLY ANOTHER REGULATION
WAS PASSED ALLOWING A PLATFORM
TO BECOME PART OF A STATE
ARTIFICIAL REEF PROGRAM SO LONG
AS THE STATE ASSUMES TITLE IN
LIABILITY OF THE STRUCTURE. AND
U. S. COAST GUARD NAVIGATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS ARE MET. THE COAST
GUARD USUALLY REQUIRES AN EIGHTY
FIVE FOOT CLEARANCE BETWEEN THE
SEA SURFACE AND REMAINING
STRUCTURE. FOR MANY YEARS
CALIFORNIA DID NOT HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT MET THESE FEDERAL
CRITERIA CALIFORNIA DO YOU HAVE
AN ARTIFICIAL REEF PROGRAM. BUT
IT WAS FOCUSED ON CONSTRUCTING
REEFS THAT MIMIC NATURAL REEFS
PREFERRING MATERIAL SUCH AS
QUARRY ROCK AND CONCRETE STOP
ALL. EFFORTS TO CHANGE STATE LAW
STARTED AFTER THE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX REMOVAL OF THE FOR
EACH PLATFORM IS BUYING CHEVRON
I'M NOT SURE SOME SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY- AT THAT TIME THE
INDUSTRY SOFT PERMISSION TO
AVOID REQUIREMENTS FOR FULL
REMOVAL- BUT NEVERTHELESS-
BECAUSE WE DID NOT HAVE A STATE
LAWFUL REMOVAL WAS STILL
REQUIRED. BEGINNING IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THERE WERE SEVERAL
ATTEMPTS TO ENACT LEGISLATION TO
ASSIST DALGLEISH A STATE ROUTES
TO REPROGRAM BUT THEY FELT
INTERFACE OF SUBSTANTIAL
OPPOSITION. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
WHAT CHANGED IN TWENTY TEN WHEN
AB TWO FIVE OH THREE PASSED.
THIS WAS THE CALIFORNIA MARINE
RESOURCES LEGACY ACT. THE BILL
PASSED IN LARGE PART BECAUSE IT
REQUIRED A ROBUST SCIENTIFIC
INQUIRY COMPARING THE IMPACT AND
BENEFITS TO THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT A FULL REMOVAL
VERSUS PARTIAL REMOVAL AND THEN
NOT IN OUR OFFICE WOULD RESULT
IN A DETERMINATION OF WHICH
OPTION WOULD RESULT IN A NET
BENEFIT TO CREATE ENVIRONMENTS.
THE SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS WAS
INCLUDED IN SECTION SIX SIX ONE
THREE OF THE LAW WHICH WAS BASED
ON A FEW THOUSAND UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DECOMMISSIONING
REPORT QUESTIONED. WHETHER ONE
OIL PLATFORM IN AND OF ITSELF-
CREATED ECOLOGICAL BENEFIT. THE
BILL ALSO PASSED BECAUSE THERE
WAS A COST SAVING OUR OUR
KASHIRI PROVISION AND BECAUSE
THE BILL INCLUDED AN
INDEMNIFICATION PROVISION. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. THE SCIENTIFIC
ANALYSIS INCLUDING THE TWENTY
TEN LAW IS CRITICAL TO DECISION
MAKING REGARDING POPCORN
DECOMMISSIONING I WILL FOCUS ON
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WILL
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AS EACH
PLATFORM IS REVIEWED ON ITS OWN
MERITS FIRST ECOLOGICAL ISSUES.
ALSO NEED TO CONSIDER SETTING
AND PRESENCE OF OTHER HABITAT IN
THE VICINITY EACH PLATFORM IS
DIFFERENT THEY RANGE IN DEPTH
FROM THIRTY EIGHT TO ALMOST
TWELVE HUNDRED FEET. THE
PLATFORM WILL HAVE TO BE TOPPLED
BOB OR MOVED TO COMPLY WITH
NAVIGATIONAL SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
. SO THAT NOW WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER HOW THE LOSS OF THE TOP
OF THE POPS FOR ME AFFECT
REPRODUCTION AND OTHER ISSUES
IDENTIFIED IN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REPORT. INCIDENTALLY
THE THREE PLATFORMS IN STATE
WATERS OFF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ARE ALL INVESTED EIGHTY FIVE
FEET SO THEY MAY NOT EVEN BE
ELIGIBLE FOR PARTIAL
DECOMMISSIONING UNDER COAST
GUARD NAVIGATIONAL REQUIREMENTS
. THEY ALSO SHOULD ALSO CONSIDER
WHAT THE EFFECTIVE CLEANING
OPERATIONS MAY BE ON THE SEA
LIFE BUT THE PLATFORMS. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. ANOTHER ECOLOGICAL
ISSUE RELATES TO THE HABITAT
VALUE OF THE STRUCTURE-
WHICHEVER REMOVED THE FORAGE
PLATFORMS OFFSHORE SUMMERLIN THE
COMPANY LEFT BEHIND MASSIVE HI
KATIE SPAHN'S PIPES AND DEAD
SHELLS THE PILES ARE TWENTY FIVE
TO TWENTY EIGHT FEET IN HEIGHT
AND A HUNDRED EIGHTY TO TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX FEET IN
DIAMETER AND WHAT AFTER WE MOVED
AMOUNTS CHEVRON ASSERTD THAT
THEY WERE PROVIDING VALUABLE
HABITAT. HOWEVER THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION CONDUCTED A STUDY IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE THAT THAT THAT
THAT DETERMINE THAT AMOUNTS WERE
NOT. PROVIDING HABITAT VALUE. NO
SLIDE PLEASE. ANOTHER ECOLOGICAL
ISSUES THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF
FISHING ONCE WELL PRODUCTION
CEASES THE STRUCTURES MAY BE
OPEN TO FISHING THE SCIENTIFIC
ANALYSIS MUST CONSIDER HOW THAT
WILL AFFECT THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT. NEXT PLEASE.
FINALLY A TWO THOUSAND SIX
REPORT DISCLOSED THE PRESENCE OF
NON NATIVE SPECIES ON OFFSHORE
PLATFORMS THIS SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED IN THE SCIENTIFIC
ANALYSIS AS WELL. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. ANOTHER ISSUE THAT MUST
BE ADDRESSED IN THE SCIENTIFIC
ANALYSIS IS THE PRESENCE OF
TOXIC CONTAMINATION THERE ARE
TWO THOUSAND ONE STATE LANDSCAPE
STUDY OF THE CHEVRON MOUNTS
SIGNIFICANT LEVELS OF MANY TOXIC
POLLUTANTS INCLUDING ARSENIC
HEAVY METALS PETROLEUM
HYDROCARBONS AND PH'S. BOB FORM
SITES ARE NOT COMPLETELY
RESTORED AND CLEANED UP WE WILL
FACE A PROBLEM OF LEGACY
POLLUTION IN THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT. THEREFORE ANY
REVIEW OF DECOMMISSIONING
OPTIONS WILL NEED TO CONSIDER
THE PRESENCE OF POTENTIAL TOXIC
CONTAMINATION IN THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT IF. THE SITES ARE
NOT FULLY CLEANED UP AND
RESTORED. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
FORTUNATELY SOME STUDIES ARE
ALREADY UNDERWAY THAT WILL HELP
INFORM THE SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW FOR
EACH PROPERTY COMMISSION
PROPOSAL. ZERO OCEAN ENERGY
MANAGEMENT IS PREPARING A
PROGRAMMATIC ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT STATEMENT FOR ALL
PLATFORMS OFFSHORE CALIFORNIA-
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED- AND AS-
JENNIFER LOOKING AS YOU POINTED
OUT BE A DRAFT ENVIRONMENT
IMPACT STATEMENT IS DUE OUT
FEBRUARY. ALL WE'VE ALREADY
SUBMITTED A SCOPING COMMENTS AND
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD- TO
REVIEWING THIS BROUGH IMPACT
STATEMENT WHICH WILL EVALUATE
DECOMMISSIONING IMPAX
ALTERNATIVES WHICH COULD BE-
YOUR PARTIAL VERSUS FULL REMOVAL
BUT ALSO COULD LOOK AT
ALTERNATIVE TECHNOLOGIES. AND
MITIGATION MEASURES- THIS. I
STATEMENT WILL FULFILL OUR
EXISTING STATE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR ENSURING
COMPREHENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW BOSTON SCIENTIFIC
ANALYSIS COMPARING. VARIOUS
DECOMMISSIONING OPTIONS
ADDITIONALLY- WE'RE GOING TO-
SEE OUR FIRST PROJECT SPECIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW STUDENTS
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION WAS
EXPECTED TO. BEGIN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS FOR
PLATFORM HOLY DECOMMISSIONING
THIS YEAR SO WE WILL HELP OFFICE
PROGRAMMATIC LOOK AT THE IMPACTS
AND ALTERNATIVES AND MITIGATION
MEASURES WE WILL ALSO HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF EIGHT PLATFORM
SPECIFIC ANALYSIS. SO WORKSITE
THAT WE WERE MAKING THIS
TRANSITION PROBLEMS ARE BEING
DECOMMISSIONED GOT THESE GREAT
STUDIES REPORTS COMING UP AND WE
ENCOURAGE ALL THOSE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROCESS- WE ARE ALSO
FORTUNATE THAT WE ALREADY
PASSED- A STATE LAW THAT
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES
DECOMMISSIONING ALTERNATIVES AND
REQUIRES. ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
AS WELL AS A ROBUST SCIENTIFIC
ANALYSIS. AND WHAT THAT NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE- WE DO HAVE SOME
INFORMATION ON OUR WEBSITE- BUT
THE LINK IN THE SLIDE HERE. AND
THE LOOK FORWARD TO ANY
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS AT THE END
OF THE PANEL PRESENTATIONS AND
I'LL PASS IT OVER TO DAMON A
COPY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU IS CRAP.
GREAT THANKS SO MUCH LINDA AND
GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS DAMOND
THEY GOT ME I'M A SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH THE NATURISTS
TENSE COUNCIL- THAT WAS A GREAT
PRESENTATION THANK YOU LINDA I
THINK AGAIN ATTIC THE SLIDES
DOWN- THANK YOU TO SOMEONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOUS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS IN
YOUR STAFF ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING.
I WILL ECHO WHAT LINDA SAID IN
THAT THIS IS A VERY TIMELY GIVEN
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING
AROUND PLATFORM DECOMMISSIONING
AND IN THE WAKE OF LAST
OCTOBER'S OIL SPILL I THINK
WE'RE ALL STILL RECOVERING- FROM
THE SHOCK AND COLLECTIVE
OUTRAGE- THAT THIS THESE OIL
DISASTERS KEEP HAPPENING- BUT
I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
TO HARNESS THIS OUTRAGE AND KEEP
THIS ISSUE IN THE SPOTLIGHT SO
THE PUBLIC CAN GET THE
INFORMATION- IT THE
DECOMMISSIONING EFFORTS THE PART
ABOUT AS THOSE I GET UP AND
RUNNING. WE HEARD LINDA TALK
ABOUT OUR EXISTING FEDERAL AND
STATE LAWS AROUND. AND THAT
BRINGS US TO NEXT STEPS AND THEN
THE TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE-
ENVIRONMENT REVIEW PROCESS
EITHER HAPPENING- THE BIG
TAKEAWAY HERE IS THAT THESE
PROCESSES ARE HAPPENING NOW ARE
THESE A FORMAL ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESSES AND THEY'RE
HAPPENING AT BOTH THE FEDERAL
AND STATE LEVELS. AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AS YOU HEARD- BASICALLY
BACK IN JULY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TOOK ITS FIRST STEPS
TOWARD DECOMMISSIONING OIL AND
GAS INFRASTRUCTURE OFF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COAST SO THE
AGENCY THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT BONE
THE BUREAU OF OCEAN ENERGY
MANAGEMENT. ISSUE WHAT'S CALLED
A NOTICE OF INTENT TO PREPARE A
PROGRAMMATIC ENVIRONMENT IMPACT
STATEMENT A P. E. I. S. UNDER
THE NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY ACT OR NEPA AT THE END OF
LIFE WAS IT A DOCUMENT THAT WAS
RELEASED TO PROVIDE SOME BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT. THE
FORTHCOMING REVIEW EFFORT AND
INVITED STAKEHOLDERS TO COMMENTS
ON THE SCOPE OF THE REVIEW- AND
STICKLE OF DONE THAT AND OF THE
SCOPING LETTERS ARE OUT THERE
FOR US FOLKS TAKE A LOOK AT AND
STATE LEVEL AS JENNIFER
MENTIONED- THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IS PLANNING TO START
THE SEQUEL PROCESS- FOR THE
DECOMMISSIONING PLATFORM HOLLY
AS- LINDA HAD MENTIONED LATER
THIS YEAR. AND YOU KNOW WITH THE
FROM THE COMMISSION'S WEBSITE
YOU CAN SEE THAT THEY'RE
PLANNING TO HIRE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTANTS STERN
LATER THIS YEAR TO PREPARE THE
REVIEW I WHICH IS JENNIFER
MENTIONED MOST LIKELY WILL BE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT FOR
E. I. R. THIS PROCESS- THE
SIMPLE SINGLE PROCESS WILL START
LATER THIS YEAR AND WILL INVOLVE
ROBUST- PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDER
OUTREACH IS VERY IMPORTANT- AND
WILL INFORM THE DECOMMISSIONING
PLAN FOR PLATFORM HOLLY- WHICH
AS JENNIFER MENTIONED WILL THEN
REQUIRE COMMISSION REVIEW AND
APPROVAL. AT A PUBLIC MEETING
NOW THESE ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
WILL BE COMPREHENSIVE THEY WILL
EVALUATE THE COMMISSIONING.
IMPACTS ALTERNATIVES AND
MITIGATION MEASURES SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO. KEEP CLOSE
EYE ON THIS. AND I JUST HAVE TO
HERE. YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO STUDY- ALL THE
OPTIONS FOR DECOMMISSIONING VERY
CAREFULLY. PERSONALLY I GREW UP
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I WAS AS
OUT RAISES ANYONE TO HEAR ABOUT
THE OIL SPILL THAT WAS
THREATENING TO TEAR SPEECHES
THAT I WENT TO AS A KID I STILL
GO TO AS AN ADULT. I LIKE ALL OF
YOU I'M EXCITED THAT THE END OF
FOSSIL FUEL PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA IS WITHIN REACH. BUT
PLATFORM DECOMMISSIONING AS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY IS VERY
COMPLEX AND NEEDS TO BE DONE
THOUGHTFULLY AND IN A WAY THAT
IS MAXIMALLY PROTECTIVE OF THE
ENVIRONMENT. THE REVIEW PROCESS
THESE ARE DESIGNED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT HAPPENS. AND AS WE
MENTIONED THEY WILL ALSO HELP
FULFILL THE EXISTING STATE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS. FOR ENSURING THAT-
COMPREHENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW AND A ROBUST SCIENTIFIC
ANALYSIS. COMPARING THE VARIOUS
DEEP MISSING OPTIONS ARE CARRIED
OUT. UP AND FINAL NOTE HERE I-
YOU KNOW OUR GROUPS ARE HERE TO
FOCUS ON THE ENVIRONMENT IMPACTS
IN THESE REVIEW PROCESSES THAT
ARE UNDER WAY BUT SINCE COST IS
ONE OF THE TOPICS COVERED IN
THIS HEARING. I DIDN'T WANT TO
ECHO- SOME OF THE- THE REMARKS
THAT I'VE HEARD AND EMPHASIZE
CALIFORNIA STRONG AND
LONGSTANDING POLLUTER PAYS
POLICY WHICH AND I DO SEE AND
MANY OTHER GROUPS VOICE SUPPORT
THE OIL INDUSTRY. ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
RESPONSIBLE FOR CLEANING UP
AFTER THEMSELVES FULL STOP. ALSO
THERE WAS A REMARKS EARLIER
ABOUT- YOU KNOW THE POTENTIAL
FOR DECOMMISSIONING LEADING TO
INCREASE EXPORTS THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN MOST OF THESE-PLATFORMS WERE INSTALLED BACK IN
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES AND ARE NOT
PRODUCING MUCH OIL SO- THAT
THAT'S NOT A CONCERN HERE. AND
FINALLY THESE HEARINGS ARE
SERVING IMPORTANT PURPOSES AND
SO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
WANT TO HOLD RESPONSIBILITY
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ACCOUNTABLE-
WE WANT TO SHINE A LIGHT ON
THESE ISSUES AND KEEP THEM IN
THE SPOTLIGHT. AND WE WANT TO
GET THE WORD OUT TO THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THINGS LIKE BEES
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESSES
SO THAT HOPEFULLY PEOPLE WILL
PARTICIPATE IN THEM. SO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US HERE AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. AND THAT NUMBER FOR REAL
SHINS AND MISTER CASE YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER ACT COMMENTS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE RELATED
TO- LAST LEVEL THE- TIMELINE OR
WHICH IS TIME TO QUESTION YEAH
ABOUT THE ONLY OTHER THING I
WOULD. LIKE TO MENTION IS EVEN
BEFORE- ARE AT SEQUEL PROCESS ON
PLATFORM HOLLY WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF- DECOMMISSIONING TWO
OTHER OFFSHORE OPERATIONS SO
RINCON ISLAND IS OFF SHORE AND
VENTURA COUNTY. WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF DOING A FEASIBILITY
STUDY FOR THOSE DE COMMISSIONING
OPTIONS AND WE'LL START. AT SEA
WILL PROCESS THIS YEAR AS WELL
AND THEN ALSO ASSOCIATE WITH
PLATFORM HOLLY ARE THE WHAT WE
REFER TO AS APPEARS FOR TWENTY
ONE- FACILITIES AND THESE ARE
TWO OF THE LAST TWO REMAINING
SHORES OWN PEERS- THAT ARE
RELATED TO OIL PRODUCTION. WE
PLUGGED AND ABANDONED THAT THOSE
WELLS- PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC WE
JUST RELEASED THE DRAFT YEAH I
ARE FOR FULL REMOVAL OF THOSE
FACILITIES- LAST FRIDAY- WITH
THE FORTY FIVE DAY PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD WITH THAT WHOLE.
DISSIPATION THAT OUR COMMISSION
WILL CONSIDER THAT PROJECT IN
CERTIFYING THE I. R. IN APRIL.
OF THIS YEAR. AND AS YOU OUTLINE
- THE STEPS THERE. WITH
DECOMMISSIONING. WHAT IS THE
EXPECTED TIME LINE FROM FROM.
START TO FINISH. FOR
DECOMMISSIONING OF ONE. RIGHT
RIGHT WELL IT'S VERY HIGHLY
DEPENDENT ON- HOW LONG IT TAKES
TO PLUG AND ABANDON WELLS SO FOR
EXAMPLE WITH PLATFORM HOLLY- BUT
FOR THE PANDEMIC WE WOULD HAVE
LIKELY BEEN DONE WITH THE PUP.
PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT- THAT
WE ANTICIPATE THE- LEVINE AN
ABANDONMENT OF THOSE THIRTY
WELLS TO TAKE ANOTHER TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND THEN- WE CAN
START FOCUSING ON THE
DECOMMISSIONING AND THAT'S GOING
TO BE DEPENDENT ON. AND
RECEIVING THAT- RIGHT
APPROPRIATION DEPENDING ON THE
LEVEL OF THE COMMISSIONING FOR
PLATFORM HOLLY AND THAT SORT OF
THING BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING-%
AND LINDA MAY KNOW THIS BETTER
THAN I DO- AND SHE WAS ACTIVELY
INVOLVED- THE CHEVRON FOUR EIGHT
SHALL MOUNT FOREST THAT
PLATFORMS. PROBABLY TOOK I DON'T
KNOW BETWEEN FIVE AND TEN YEARS
TO FULLY REMOVAL TO REMOVE- FROM
THE PLUG IN ABOUT A MINUTE THE
WELLS AND THEN FULL HOUR AT THAT
AB PLATFORM FACILITY REMOVAL BUT
LINDA MAY KNOW THAT BETTER.
LINDA ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON
THAT ON THE TIMELINE QUESTION.
THANK YOU- I DON'T RECALL I
THINK IT IT DIDN'T TAKE- SUPER
LONG YOU KNOW BACK THEN IS- IS
LOOKING AS YOU MENTIONED- BAKER
BERMAN NEGATIVE DECLARATION
BECAUSE IT WAS BASED ON THE FACT
THAT NOT THE FULL PLATFORM WOULD
BE REMOVING THE SITE WOULD BE
RESTORED TO ITS NATURAL
CONDITION AND THEY'RE IN THE
RIGHT ENVIRONMENT WOULD BE-
RESTORED- WE GOT INVOLVED
QUICKLY AFTER THE PLATFORMS HAVE
BEEN REMOVED BRANDI'S MASSIVE
DEBRIS MOUNDS WERE LAUGHED AT.
TWENTY SOME YEARS LATER WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO GET THEM CLEANED
UP. QUESTION FOR MEMBERS. A
COUPLE FOR JENNIFER ACTUALLY
SILVA ITHINK IT'S WE'RE CLOSE
ENOUGH. PLATFORM HOLLY HOW ARE
THEY PLUG MODEL CONCRETE GUY SO
I THINK THAT'S HOW IT'S DONE BUT
YEAH YOU JUST TAKE A CAP AND PUT
IT ON OR IS IT FILLED WITH
CONCRETE AND DONE IT'S FILLED
WITH CEMENT- AND IT'S A PRETTY
INVOLVED PROCESS BECAUSE- MANY
OF THESE WELLS ARE RE
PRESSURIZING- IN FACT- IF. JUST
IN DECEMBER I GAVE AN UPDATE-
THAT WE HAD PLAYED IN THREE OF
THE THIRTY WELLS AND FINISH THAT
AND WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE
FOURTH HOWEVER ONE OF THOSE
THREE WELLS WERE RE
PRESSURIZING- AND SO WE HAVE TO
GO BACK IN AND- CONDUCTS SOME
ADDITIONAL WORK- ON AND TO BE
ABLE TO COMPLETELY AND SAFELY.
PLUG AND ABANDON THE SO IT'S
PRIMARILY CEMENT- AND- IT'S AT
NOW I'M GETTING INTO IT I HAD
EXPERTISE THAT'S WELL BEYOND ME.
MY GOD. AT WORK THOSE PLANS-
TEN. THE TO- THERE'S NO CHIU OF
OR BEING A TO LEAVE- AFTER THE
COMPLETE PLUG ABANDONED OF. THE
TIME WHILE THE COMMISSION PART.
PREMIERES AN OPERATOR SAYS IS
NOT PRODUCING ENOUGH OIL SO IT'S
TIME TO DO COMMISSION THEY COME
TO YOU YOU DON'T COME AND TELL
ME I HAVE TO DO COMMISSION AND
SHUT IT DOWN HOW DOES THAT.
PROCESS WORK YEAH SO- SO BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THAT THE LEGAL-
FRAMEWORK- HAS BEEN SET UP SINCE
THE NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
CUNNINGHAM SHALL LAUGH- THERE IS
NO TERM ASSOCIATED WITH OFFSHORE
LEASES SO IT'S THEY DON'T
EXPIRE. BY A CERTAIN DATE AND
THE TERM IS- ESSENTIALLY IN
ECONOMIC TERMS THAT'S DICTATED
AND DETERMINED BY THE OPERATE IN
THEMSELVES SO EVEN THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION. RENNIE OTHER
STATE ENTITY CANNOT COME IN AND
SAY IT'S NOT ECONOMIC ANYMORE
FOR YOU TO DO THIS OPERATOR YOU
HAVE TO DO WE'RE GOING TO
TERMINATE YOUR LEASE AND THEY
DETERMINED THAT- AND SO- ONCE.
AT IT HAS BEEN DETERMINED- BY
THEM THAT THEY NO LONGER WANT TO
CONTINUE TO PRODUCE WHICH WAS
THE SITUATION WHAT THAT FOR
EACH- PLATFORMS FOR CHEVRON-
THEN DATE AS ESSENTIALLY APPLY
TO THE COMMISSION. ALONG WITH
ALL THE OTHER REGULATORY
ENTITLEMENTS THEY NEED- TO
PURSUE THE PLUGGING AND
ABANDONMENT OF THE WELLS AND
THEN- PURSUE DECOMMISSIONING OF
THE FACILITY. THIS IS. THE ONE
EXCEPTION IS IF THE LESSEE IS-
OR THE AND THE OPERATOR IS NOT.
OUR OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR
LEASE TERMS AND THEN THERE'S A
WHOLE- ACT COMPLIANCE EFFORT-
THAT WE PURSUE- THAT COULD
RESULT IN TERMINATION OF AN
OFFSHORE PRODUCTION LEASE THAT
HAS NOT OCCURRED IN STATE
WATERS. HOWEVER A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO- THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION DID TERMINATE I STATE
PIPELINE LEASE THAT CONNECTED A
FEDERAL FEDERAL PLATFORM
PRODUCTION PLATFORMS TO THE LONG
TERM DISABILITY. FOR NON
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LEASE TERMS
AND THAT IS AN SHUT DOWN THE
FEDERAL PLATFORM OKAY. IT WAS AN
ACTUAL TO GET THIS STATE HAVE
BEEN SAY IN ALL THE FED PLATFORM
THAT ARE OUT. THEN I JUST WANT
TO REMIND COLLEAGUES. THE
PLATTS. OIL SPILL IT HUNT BEACH
IT WOULD NOT COME THE PLAQUE.
AND ANCHORED. THE PIPELINE THAT
RAN FROM THE OFFICE WORK TO THE
ON TO THE SHORE. THAT IS WHERE
WE GOT TO GET CRITICAL TO WATCH
THE BANKERS AND ALL THE SHIPS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE PORT. AND
THEN ONE OTHER QUESTION I'M
GONNA GO FORTH OF DAMON. SO THAT
WE'RE NOT USING THAT MUCH OIL IN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA CONSUMES
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION GALLONS
OF OILA DAY. SO FOR NOT
PRODUCING IT IN CALIFORNIA STILL
GOING TO COME HERE TO BE
REFINED. FUEL WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CHANGE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FROM OIL TO ELECTRICITY
OVERNIGHT AS CAN BE A SLOW
PROCESS WE CAN'T GET TOO FAR
AHEAD OF THE GAME AND INCLUDING
THANK YOU FOR THAT BUT I JUST
WANT A CAR FACTS I THINK THE
POINT THAT DAMON WAS THIS AT. IN
WAS RELATED TO THE AMOUNT OF
PRODUCTION THAT IS BEING
GENERATED FROM THE OFFSHORE
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT
OFFSHORE PRODUCTION AND IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS FOR
ONE THIRD. OF 1% OF ALL US OIL
PRODUCTION I THINK THAT WAS
WE'RE STILL CONSUMING ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION GALLONS OF OIL
CALIFORNIA AND THAT VERY LITTLE
OF IT IS BEING GENERATED BY THIS
OFFER A PATH SO IT'S STILL
COMING HERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. AB THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT
JENNIFER JUST A QUICK QUESTION I
KNOW YOU POINTED OUT THAT- WOULD
REDUCE TO COMMIT BUDGET
COMMISSION APPLIED FROM THE
OPERATOR DARNLEY'S ON THE HOOK
OF FOR THE FOR THE PAYMENT BUT
THERE'S BEEN SOME INSTANCES
WHERE THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN. IN
YOUR OPINION DO YOU THINK THAT
THAT CAUGHT COSTS COULD GO TO
THE TAXPAYERS. IN THAT SITUATION
WHERE THE OPERATOR FILES FOR
BANKRUPTCY AND COMPLETELY
LIQUIDATE- YES IN FACT THAT-
WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH PLATFORM
HOLLY TO A CERTAIN EXTENT. AND
RINCON ISLAND- TO A LARGE EXTENT
SO. IN BOTH THOSE SITUATIONS THE
OPERATOR. FILED FOR- AT
BANKRUPTCY AND COMPLETELY-
LIQUIDATED AS A- ENTITY- WE'RE
ACTUALLY STILL- A LITIGATING
AGAINST THE BENNETT CO TRUSTEE.
IN BANKRUPTCY COURT TO THIS DAY-
WITH PLATFORM HOLLY- THAT PRIOR
OPERATOR WAS EXXON MOBIL. AND
BETWEEN THE PRIVATE AGREEMENT
YOU KNOW SALE AGREEMENT BETWEEN
ACTS ON INVENTIV HEALTH- AND
THEN ALSO THE CONDITIONS THAT
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
PLACED ON BOTH THE AXON AND
VANIKORO. WHEN APPROVING THAT
ASSIGNMENT- EXXON IS- STILL
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
THE PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH PLATFORM
HOLLY. AND THE- DECOMMISSIONING
BONA FIDE LEGAL DISPUTE BETWEEN
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION AN
AXE ON TO THE EXTENT OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY AND OBLIGATIONS.
AND SO THAT IS WHY- AS A
SETTLEMENT- WHILE EXXON IS- PAIN
FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE PLUGIN
IN BAMA AND THE DECOMMISSIONING.
THE STATE THROUGH THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION IS- OPERATING
AND MAINTAINING. THE PLATFORM
THE DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS AND
MAKE MAINTENANCE AS WELL AS- AND
MEETING ALL THE REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DECOMMISSIONING. CELL THAT WAS
THE RESULT OF A SETTLEMENT OF
LITIGATION WE KNOW HOW MUCH THAT
IS THAT WOULD BE THE DURING
LITIGATION HOW MUCH THAT WOULD
BE GOING BACK TO THE STATE WHICH
ULTIMATELY COMES TO THE
TAXPAYER. SO WE HAVE. SECURED
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF BUDGET
YEAR. AND TEN MILLION DOLLAR IN.
A. HOLLY I'M WITH THE THAT- PLUS
WE HAD A TWO TWO DOLLAR BY. WE
BELIEVE. WILL COVER THE
REMAINING- HAVE COVERED THE
STATE'S COST SO FAR AND WILL
COVER THE REMAINING STATE CLASS.
OR EXXON MOBIL- WE DO NOT HAVE
SPECIFIC- COSTS- THAT THEY HAVE
SPENT SO FAR THAT THEY'RE
ESTIMATING THE COST BUT WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DETERMINE BASED ON
THEIR COURT FILINGS IN THE
BANKRUPTCY. IS THAT- AT LEAST
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC THEY WERE
ESTIMATING THE FULL THEIR COSTS
FOR FULL DECOMMISSIONING AT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. THAT HAS ONLY GONE UP
BECAUSE- WE HAD TO STOP. ALL
PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT WORK
ONCE THE PANDEMIC HIT- FOR OVER
A YEAR BECAUSE OF SAFETY ISSUES-
FOR THE- WORKERS ON THE PLATFORM
ULTIMATELY THEN THE- THE COST
THAT'S COMING FROM THE STATE OF
THE COMES FROM THE TAXPAYER IS
THAT CORRECT. I YES I BELIEVE SO
THANK YOU. THE JET IT'S COMING
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. ASSEMBLY
BRANDS THANK YOU ARE YOU JUST
DESCRIBED TWO DIFFERENT
PROCESSES RIGHT ONE. WHERE EXXON
MOBIL IS A PARTNER IN PLUGGING
THAT WELL THE STATE HAS PUT IN
AN AMOUNT. EXXON IS PUTTING THEM
OUT IN ANOTHER WHERE. THE
OPERATOR. FILE BANKRUPTCY OR
CLAIM FINANCIAL INSOLVENCY IN
THE STATE IS ON THE HOOK. FOR
ALL OF IT. WHICH OF THOSE TWO
SITUATIONS WOULD YOU SAY IS MORE
COMMONPLACE BECAUSE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THE LATTER
WHERE OPERATORS CLAIM INSOLVENCY
IS ACTUALLY PART OF THE LARGER
GAME OF OWNERSHIP. THAT AS
YOU'VE DESCRIBED IN THE LAWSUIT
EXXON TRIED TO DO. ABOUT THROUGH
THAT THROUGH THE AGREEMENT ENDED
UP BEING LIABLE NONETHELESS. YES
SO- I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO THOSE
OPERATIONS THAT THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION MANAGES- AND OVERSEAS
AND SO IN TERMS OF THE REMAINING
THREE STATE PLATFORMS AND-
OFFSHORE ORANGE COUNTY- B.
TWELVE- THE AT. PARENTAL
GUARANTEES- FROM THE PRIOR
OPERATORS- THAT ASSIGNMENT
CONDITIONS THE BONDS AND THE
OTHER LIABILITY PROTECTION
MEASURES THAT WE HAVE PUT IN
PLACE LIKE IT PLATFORM HOLLY. A
SINKING FIND THEIR- PLUGGING AND
ABANDONING- IDLE WELLS AHEAD OF
CAL JAM'S REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE PROPERTY
LIENS- IN OUR IN THE STATE'S
FAVOR- BETWEEN ALL OF THAT FOR
THE REMAINING THREE PLATFORMS
PLUS CAL GEMS RECENT- AT SUCCESS
SAID REESE- GETTIN BONDS. FROM
FREEPORT MAC MORAN FOR PLATFORM
ASTOR AND EVA AND THEN C. R. C.
FOR PLATFORM AND ME- I DON'T SEE
THE SAME SITUATION HAPPENING
THERE THAT I. HAVE SEEN AT
RINCON ISLAND RINCON ISLAND WAS
ONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE-
THE COMMISSION AND THE STATE
ACTUALLY DID NOT HAVE ANY KIND
OF APPROVAL AUTHORITY OVER THE
ASSIGNMENT OF THOSE LEASES THE
PRIOR OPERATOR. HAD GONE INTO
BANKRUPTCY AND THOSE LEASE
ASSETS WERE SOLD TO RINCON L. L.
P. L. C. THROUGH THE BANKRUPTCY
AND THE STATE HAD NO- PROACTIVE
ABILITY TO APPROVE OR DENY THAT
ASSIGNMENT. SO ALL OF THAT
HAPPENED IN FEDERAL BANKRUPTCY-
COURT AND SO. THERE WEREN'T TH
SAME KINDS OF PROTECTION IS THAT
THE STATE HAS NOW. FOR WHAT IS
REMAINING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
. ANY FINAL OF. THANK YOU
MANAGER I AM WHAT. FOUR EIGHT I
ASKED SOME QUESTIONS TO ANSWER
WHAT I IS NOT THIS IS THE SECOND
HEARING THE LAST HEARING WE WERE
AT EVERY TIME I TRY TO ASK A
QUESTION I WOULD ALWAYS BE THE
LAST ONE YOU WOULD CALL IN. AND
THEN SECOND IS I WANTED TO ASK A
QUESTION EARLIER YOU STOP ME AND
THEN WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO ASK
QUESTIONS WANT TO EVERYBODY ELSE
AND THEN ME. I'M TIRED. OF THE
POLITICS THAT YOU LIKE TO PLAY
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS OIL SPILL
IN ORANGE COUNTY. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THE NEXT TO MY DISTRICT THE
OIL SPILL HAPPENED MY DISTRICT
AS WELL STOP PLAYING THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAYBOOK. OKAY
BECAUSE MY CONSTITUENT WANTS
ANSWER AND I WOULD APPRECIATE IT
THAT I AM TREATED FAIRLY JUST
LIKE ANYBODY ELSE ON THIS
COMMISSION- AND SO EITHER IT'S
SORRY SORRY SORRY LET'S JUST
DIALING DOWN HIS. ONE OF THE
THINGS. THAT I WORK INCREDIBLY
HARD TO DO INCREDIBLY HARD IN
pGOVERNMENT IS TO WORK ACROSS THE
AISLE. AND EVEN KNOWS THAT THAT
IS TRUE. I PARTNER WITH
LEGISLATORS OF EVERY EVERY
STRIPE SO I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO RIGHT
NOW BUT THIS FORUM. IS NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO
GRANDSTAND. OR TRY TO. PLAY
POLITICS SO LET'S FOCUS ON THE
SUBJECT OF A HEARING. IF I DON'T
SEE YOUR HAND RAISED A LITTLE
HIGHER. YES THAT'S SURPRISING
BECAUSE YOU STOP ME EARLIER BUT
THAT'S OKAY AND IS NOT PLAYING
POLITICS- I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE OUR AGAIN IS THAT WE'VE
CLEARED UP FOR FUTURE. MEETINGS
THAT EVERYONE OF US HERE IS
TREATED EQUALLY AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK- JENNIFER I
HAVE A QUESTION. THE YOU
MENTIONED THE COST OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES POTENTIALLY
. WHAT IS THE COST TO AND JUST
AN APPROXIMATE I KNOW THAT EVERY
POT FORMS ARE DIFFERENT AND THE
LAMP AND- THE SIZE EVERYTHING
AND HOW LONG IT'S BEEN IN THERE
AND ETCETERA- WHAT WHAT IT COSTS
TO DECOMMISSION LIKE ONE
PLATFORM. LIKE ON AVERAGE YEAH
SO WHEN I TALKED ABOUT THAT
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AN UNDIVIDED LOT
LIABILITIES THAT HAS TO DO WITH
THE LONG BEACH OPERATIONS CALMLY
SO THOSE ARE THE FOUR APPLE OIL
ISLANDS AND THAT- WELLS THAT-
PRODUCE UNDER AND THEY'RE
LOCATED UNDERLYING THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH. THAT'S A THAT'S A
TOTALLY SEPARATE UNIQUE
SITUATION- THAT- BECAUSE OF THE
HISTORY OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THAT AREA- FOR PLATFORMS- ALL I
CAN. REALLY PROVIDE AS INSIGHT
AND I GAS OR AN ESTIMATE IS WHAT
WERE AND ANTICIPATING WITH
PLATFORM HOLLY- BECAUSE REALLY
IT COMES DOWN TO- AT. THE
SPECIFICS OF THE PLUGGING AND
ABANDONMENT OF THE WELLS WHICH
EVERY SINGLE WELL EVEN ON ONE
PLATFORM CAN BE VASTLY DIFFERENT
IN TERMS OF THEIR COMPLEXITY-
AND- THEN THE PLATFORM ITSELF
AND THE ASSOCIATED
INFRASTRUCTURE SO. WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU IS BASED ON WHAT EXXON
HAS- ESTIMATED IN THEIR COURT
FILINGS IT'S ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION BUT THAT WAS PRE
PANDEMIC AND WE'VE ONLY YOU KNOW
GONE UP IN COSTS BECAUSE OF THE
PROLONGED DELAY IN BEING ABLE TO
PURSUE THE PLUGGING AND
ABANDONMENT- PLUS THE HUNDRED
AND TEN- MILLION DOLLARS. THAT
WAS APPROPRIATED I'M THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. PLUS I MEAN IT'S A
PLATFORM HOLLY APPEARS TWENTY
ONE SOUTH OUR BEST GUESS FOR
HALL IS IT'S GOING TO BE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. MY AND MY NEXT QUESTION
IS. WOULD YOU WOULD YOUR AGENCY
OR FOR WHICH AGENCY WOULD IT BE-
WHO COULD GIVE US KIND OF LIKE A
- AND BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT TWENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN- BUT IN REVENUE. FOR
THE STATE AND THAT AND THEN
AFFECTS THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND JOBS. HAVE WE AWARE
WILL OR WHO WILL BE LOOKING INTO
HOW WE PLACE THAT TWENTY ONE
BILLION AND HELP THE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE JOBS WITH
THAT BE YOUR COMMISSION OR WHAT
OTHER AGENCIES OUT THERE. THAT
IS A GREAT QUESTION I THINK
THAT- A LOT OF THAT IS BEING
LOOKED AT IN THE PROPOSED
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- THROUGH THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL GOBIZ-
AT CAL JAM. OUR AGENCY IN TERMS
OF- THE ENERGY COMMISSION IN
TERMS OF THE WHOLE ENERGY
TRANSITION- BOTH THAT LOOKING AT
HOW WE NOT ONLY TRANSITION OUR
ENERGY PRODUCTION AND
CONSUMPTION BUT ALSO LOOKING AT
WHAT THAT MEANS FOR A TRIP
DRESSED. TRANSITION FOR WORKERS
WHAT THAT MEANS FOR- PLUGGING
AND ABANDONING AND DEALING WITH
OUR ORPHAN AND LEGACY WELLS AND
HOW WE TRANSITION THOSE WORKERS
I AM NOT THE BEST PERSON TO
SPEAK TO THAT. ALTHOUGH ARE
COMMISSION PLAYS A SMALL ROLE IN
THAT TRANSITION- AND I THINK
THERE MAY BE OTHER PANEL MEMBERS
TODAY THAT CAN SPEAK MORE
DIRECTLY TO THAT BUT I KNOW THAT
THAT IS A HUGE PRIORITY AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THAT'S BEING
ADDRESSED ON MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
LEVELS WITH MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES UNDER MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
THANK YOU AND ONE MORE QUESTION.
I KNOW IT'S TOUCH A LITTLE BIT
BY MY COLLEAGUES- THE CARGO
SHIPS. THIS SPECIFIC ONE BECAUSE
OF THE CARGO SHIPS AND THEY'RE
STILL ON. THE COASTLINE ON IN MY
DISTRICT- I KNOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S DOING THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATION AND ALL THAT OTHER
STUFF BUT THAT'S ABOUT MORE OF
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
RECENT WAS BUILT NOT SO MUCH OF
THE NEW THAT CURRENT CARGO SHIP
THE KEEPS ON COMING. ALL RIGHTS
ARE THERE CURRENTLY AND THOSE
THAT KEEPS ON COMING- ARE YOU
GUYS OUR YEAR IS YOUR AGENCY
LOOKING AT HOW CAN WE GET THESE
CARGO SHIP MOVING OR- WE
MONITORING IT MORE BETTER
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
ABOUT A YEAR NOW- OF WHEN THE
PIPELINE WAS DAMAGED BY THE
ANCHOR BOND IS TODAY OR THIS
WEEK. OR SOMETIME THIS MONTH-
AND SO I DIDN'T. WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT SOMEONE IS CURRENTLY
MONITORING THESE CARGO SHIPS
BECAUSE THIS CAN HAPPEN AGAIN
AND WE DON'T WANT TO FIND OUT A
YEAR FROM NOW. WHY IT'S LEAKING-
AND SO WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT CURRENTLY. YEAH MY BEST
GUESS AGAIN I'M NOT THE EXPERT
IN THIS AND I DO KNOW THAT IT IS
THE SUBJECT OF THE INVESTIGATION
THAT THAT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
PURSUING. BUT IN TERMS OF THE
OVERALL MANAGEMENT OF THE VESSEL
TRAFFIC- OFFSHORE IN OUR PORTS
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE U. S.
COAST GUARD THE MARINE EXCHANGE
AND THE PORTS OF LONG BEACH AND
LOS ANGELES DIRECTLY- AND THAT
FROM A SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUE- THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND- HIS
ADMINISTRATION. IS WORKING
TOWARDS MAKING A LOT OF
IMPROVEMENTS AND DOING WHAT THEY
CAN. TO WITH IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RELIEVE SOME OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES BUT IT REALLY IS A FALLS
ON- THE RESPONSIBILITY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND- MAJORITY
OF SITUATIONS. AND IT WAS JUST
ONE MORE- SLIDES YOUR SLIDES CAN
pLIGHTS THAT'S BEEN PRESENTED
TODAY WE CAN GET THEM BECAUSE-
NONE OF UP I. SOME OF US DIDN'T
GET IT OR DIDN'T WE DIDN'T SEE
IT. SO I WOULD APPRECIATE WE CAN
GET THOSE LIGHTS UP TO OUR
OFFICES. AND YOU CAN THANK YOU
GUESS MY AT THIS LIKELY START
HAS DISTRIBUTED THOSE TO YOUR
STAFF SO- THEY WILL BE WAITING
IN YOUR INBOX. AND WITH THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
THIS MORNING. AND WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND TRANSITION TO OUR
NEXT PANEL- WHICH IS DE
COMMISSIONING MEAN FOR WORKERS
AND WE ARE WELCOMING. AT
APPROACH WE HAVE IN PERSON
RIGHT- I THINK THAT WE ARE WE
ARE VIRTUALLY WELCOMING. AT ERIN
LEHANE. FROM THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
FIRST PANELIST. MORNING THANK.
HOW IS EVERYBODY OKAY. YOU'RE
FREE TODAY. TAKES IT TAKES YOUR
WORKERS THANK MY FRIEND TO
JEFFERIES THE BOILERMAKERS
CALIFORNIA. HAVING LITTLE AT
TROUBLE FIRST HAND OP WRAPPING
OF BIT OF EASING OF A LITTLE BIT
OF A AND- CONNECTION ISSUE. OKAY
TRY TO FIX MY CONNECTION. I SAID
I SEE TYSON SIGN WELL I TRIED TO
FIX MY CONNECTION HERE. OKAY
WONDERFUL THANK YOU AT AND WE
ARE WELCOMING AT TYSON BECKLEY.
HELLO EVERYBODY CAN YOU GUYS
HEAR ME OKAY YES WE CAN'T THANKS
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US FANTASTIC
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME AND SPEAK ON BEHALF OF OUR
ORGANIZED LABOR AND- UNITED
STEEL WORKERS LOCAL THREE TWENTY
SIX- I DO REPRESENT. TWO HUNDRED
NINETY MEN AND WOMEN THAT WORK
AT THE RODEO REFINERY I HEAR
WILL DEAL CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO
HEAVY INTEREST AND- KNOWLEDGE IN
THE OFFSHORE OIL INDUSTRY THAT
WAS MY PRIOR INDUSTRY BEFORE I
GOT INTO THE REFINING BUSINESS.
SO ON LIKE I SAID I MÀ
REPRESENTING THE PRESIDENT OF
LOCAL THREE TWENTY SIX. I AM A
TRANSPLANT OF THE BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AREA I HAVE SEEN. THE
OIL INDUSTRY AND WHAT IS DONE IN
PROVIDED FOR MY FAMILY AND FOR
TWO GENERATIONS OF MY
GRANDFATHER AND FATHER BEFORE
ME. ARM AND HOW MUCH THIS
INDUSTRY REALLY MEANS TO US ALL-
I'LL GET ON AFTER MISTER
JEFFRIES INTRODUCES HIMSELF BUT-
I WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. WONDERFUL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND I MISTER JEFFRIES THANKS SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
ONE. OF MONEY WAS TIMOTHY
JEFFRIES I'M WILL MAKERS
REPRESENTED CALLED MAKE IT ZERO
IN CALIFORNIA AS PER TO BE
SPECIFICALLY. WE SERVICE
REFINERIES IN THE BAY AREA HERE-
I LIKE THIS TALK ABOUT THE- BY
MEMBERS ARE WORKING REFINERS OUT
DIFFICULT TO APPRECIATE PROGRAMS
FOR YOUR PRINCIPAL M. SIX
THOUSAND HOURS. THEY THEY CHOOSE
TO BE IN THIS TYPE OF INDUSTRIES
WHAT THEY CHOOSE TO GO TO CRAP
THE DOLLAR DIRECTION THEY CHOOSE
TO GO INTO FOR WORK. AND THAT-
IN THAT- JUST. GIVEN THEM
ANOTHER JOB IS NOT WHAT WHAT WE
SEE AS AS IT IS ON THIS IS
DOABLE NOT AT ALL. THE INTEREST
FOR THESE NUMBERS THAT GO WHEN
HE'S DISABILITIES THEY WANT TO
DO THIS WORK IS WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO. THEY'RE NOT CUT OUT FOR A
LOT OF THE BLUE CROSS A LOT OF
THE OTHER TYPE WORKERS WHAT THEY
LIKE TO GET TO HIS DIRTY. AND
GETTING A FEEL THE WORK IN THE
FIELDS THERE. I WOULDN'T PLAY
THE ARMY ALSO IN MY LOCAL HERE
THERE ISN'T QUITE A NUMBER OF-
VETERANS TO COME TO THE PROGRAM
HERE I MYSELF CAME TO HIM SO
HARD THAT PROGRAM- IN THE
BUILDING TRADES HERE WHICH IS
GREAT PROGRAMS TO HELP IN
ASSISTING VETERANS. LEAVING
MILITARY COMING INTO THE
DEFENSIVE TO COME TO STOP
MINISTRIES. AT THE GAVE ME A
WONDERFUL LEG UP AND UP AND UP
OP A WONDERFUL. TO A LITTLE IN
THE BAY AREA. YOU'RE DEALING THE
BILL TO BUY A HOUSE IN THE BAY
AREA SOMETHING'S NOT FORTY
EVERYONE. AND I'M GONNA MEMBERS
OF MY LOCAL ARE. UNABLE TO BUY
HOUSES IN A BEAUTIFUL. AREA TO
TRANSPORT SOME GROUND IN THE
AREA. THE HIGH COST OF GAS WILL
AFFECT MY MEMBERS CHEST
DRASTICALLY DAY THEY HAVE TO
DRIVE ROUND DARIUS. SO IT IS FOR
THE JOBS. WE TYPICALLY WORK A
MONTH AT A FACILITY AND ONCE THE
JOB IS DONE WE GOT YOUR NEXT JOB
THAT MEANS WE GOT DR ROBERT SHOP
HIGH GAS PRICES. DEFICIT BACK MY
MEMBERSHIPS. THANK A FACT
FINANCES AND WHAT THEY CAN DO
AND IF FAMILIES. ALSO INDUSTRY
WERE ALSO. I PRIDE THIS
BOILERMAKER YOU'RE GONNA BE YOU
KNOW SECOND CHANCES WE- HAVE A
WELDING PROGRAM HAS BEEN
ACCEPTED AT THE FOLSOM COP
PRESENT. THAT WE ACCEPT- ALL
THAT REFLECT GROUP COMING OUT OF
THIS. SO WE'RE SECOND CHANCE
CITIZEN NOT COME OUT OF. GIVE
THE MOLD A LIVABLE WAGE AS WELL
TO. HELP WHICH IS PROVEN BE VERY
GOOD OUR- GOOD WELDERS IN THE-
OUT. OF INSTRUMENTS. WE SEE IF
WE CAN GET THERE AND BACK ON THE
LINE. YES MA'AM I DO I'LL
PROBABLY GONNA SELL LIKE AN ECHO
TO MISTER JEFFRIES BUT I WANT TO
BE CRYSTAL CLEAR. ABOUT WHAT
THIS INDUSTRY HAS DONE FOR NOT
ONLY MYSELF BUT THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WORK IN THESE
REFINERIES- WE'RE PROUD. TO
SUPPORT AND EMPLOY PEOPLE. THAT
HAVE SECOND CHANCES ON LIFE WE
COME FROM A VERY DIVERSE SOCIAL
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS AND PEOPLE
WITH VARYING COLLEGE EDUCATIONAL
DEGREES. ADVANCED DEGREES ALL
THE WAY TO THE TRAITS LIKE MR
JEFFREY SAID. WE EMPLOY PEOPLE
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE AND WE'RE
PROUD OF THAT. I LISTEN TO
PEOPLE DURING MY TENURE AS UNION
PRESIDENT HERE. THE RATES WILL
BE LITTLE THIS INDUSTRY- FOR
PERSONAL REASONS AND POLITICAL
AGENDAS IN THE NAME OF GLOBAL
WARMING. THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
FALSE THIS INDUSTRY CHANGES
LIVES I'M PROUD TO BE A PART OF
THIS I'M PROUD OF MY FAMILY
COMES FROM THIS. I'M PROUD TO
REPRESENT THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
WORK IN THIS INDUSTRY. ONE THING
I WOULD BE CRYSTAL CLEAR ON. IS
THAT WHEN I LISTEN TO PEOPLE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS TALK ABOUT
JUST TRANSITION FOR OUR MEMBERS
TO TRANSITION INTO OTHER JOBS.
AND REVENUES. THAT IS NOT WHAT
WE'RE INTERESTED. WE ARE PROUD
OF WHAT. I CAME FROM A VERY
UNIQUE BACKGROUND I WAS A
PERSONAL BASEBALL PLAYER FROM
SENEGAL PADRES FOR FIVE YEARS
BEFORE I STARTED WORKING HERE.
WANTED MORE DECISION A COMMON TO
GET INTO THE WORKFORCE I CHOSE
THE OIL GAS INDUSTRY. BECAUSE
THEY PROVIDE LIVING WAGE CAREERS. FOR MEN AND WOMEN. ALL MAKE
THAT VERY CLEAR THAT THEY DO NOT
WORK. ALL WHAT THEY TALK ABOUT
INNER GOALS WAS TO. INTO THE
STORE AND- THE FOR CYLINDERS
VETERANS MEMBERS. WE PROVIDE A
SERVICE COME ON IN THE STATE
HELLO. THAT IS NEEDED EVERY DAY
I HEARD SOMEONE TALK ABOUT ONE
POINT THREE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION GALLONS OF FOSSIL FUELS
USE MR CALIFORNIA. THIS PRODUCT
NEEDS TO BE PRODUCED IN
CALIFORNIA WE DO WHAT THE SAFEST
WE DO WITH THE CLEANEST AND WE
DO WHAT THE BEST WAY OF ANYBODY
IN THE WORLD. ANOTHER THING THAT
I WANT TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR ON.
IS THE CONSTANT RED TAPE. OFF OF
THOSE YOU ARE AWARE WE HAVE A
VERY. BREATHTAKING AN AMAZING
PROJECT TAKING PLACE THE OLD
SIXTY SIX MOBILE CALIFORNIA OUR
COMPANY HAS FOREST HILL MAYOR.
AND ASK TO GET A PROJECT TO
PROVIDE RENEWABLE FUELS TO
PRODUCE RENEWABLE FUELS FOR
LIQUID FUELS WILL USE OF
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THE CONSTANT
RED TAPE. IS CONSTANTLY BEING
GROWN BY EXTREMIST ACTIVIST THAT
STONEWALL THESE PROJECTS THAT
KEEP MEN AND WOMEN ON THE BOY
BUT HELP ME CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
AGENDA GOALS AND CLIMATE ACTION
GOALS. THIS NEEDS TO STOP WE
NEED SUPPORT FROM NOT ONLY STATE
LEGISLATORS OR FROM THE PUBLIC
AS WELL. WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN THESE FACILITIES OUR
STATE TO PROVIDE OVER 3% OF
CALIFORNIA'S GDP PER YEAR OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRY. SO I WANNA
MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR AGAIN THAT
THESE EXTREMISTS. YOU'RE NOT
REPRESENTS. THE JUST TRANSITION
IF YOU WANT TO LOOK AT A MODEL
OF WHAT TRANSITION LOOKS LIKE.
LOOK AT THE PHILLIPS SIXTY SIX
AUDIO REFINERY AND I'M PROUD TO
BE PARTNERING WITH MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN THE TRADES ARE
GONNA HELP BUILD THIS FACILITY
IN MAKING A TECHNOLOGICALLY
ADVANCED WORLD LEADER AND MODEL
FOR COMPANIES. TO FOLLOW FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
US AND DATA FOR EACH INTO. RE
ABLE TO GET ERIN BACK ON THE
PHONE. I AM HERE NOW CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES WONDERFUL YES WE
CAN THINK SO MUCH AND-
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ERIN MY HAND ON BEHALF OF THE
HALF A MILLION MEMBERS OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA- AS
YOU ALL KNOW. THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES HAVE BUILT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
RENEWABLE ENERGY. YOU SET THE
BAR WORLDWIDE AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE GREEN AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO PUSH THOSE CALLS. BUT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT A JUST TRANSITION A
TERM OF THE BUILDING TRADES
THAT- WE- NEED. WHERE AND LITTLE
APPREHENSION WE DO NOT
ANTICIPATE ANY TRANSITION WHERE
OUR WORKERS OUR INDUSTRIAL
WORKERS ARE MOVED INTO A
PROFESSION IT IS NOT EIGHT
INDUSTRIAL TRADE- OUR INTENTION
IN OUR FIGHT IS IN MAINTAINING
THE JOBS THAT ARE MEMBERS-
CURRENTLY HAVE. CURRENTLY LOGGED
IN ENABLE THEM TO FEED THEIR
FAMILIES. THE JOB SHOULD REMAIN
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
KILL THE STATE IS NO LONGER
DEPENDENT ON FOSSIL FUELS. AT
THE SAME TIME SIMULTANEOUSLY WE
SEE- MOVING OUR MEMBERS INTO NEW
TECHNOLOGIES NEW INDUSTRIES LIKE
CARBON CAPTURE AND HYDROGEN AND
OTHER NEW FUELS THAT ALLOW
INDUSTRIAL WORKERS TO REMAIN
INDUSTRIAL WORKERS. IT WILL
ALLOW THE CHILDREN OF INDUSTRIAL
WORKERS TO CHOOSE TO FOLLOW
THEIR PARENTS PASSED TO BE
INDUSTRIAL WORKERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- WE ARE- WE'D BE
REMISS IF WE DIDN'T MENTION. AT
NASA AND OTHER POLICIES LIKE
NAFTA THAT WERE WELL INTENTIONED
BUT HAD DEVASTATING EFFECTS. ON
BLUE COLLAR WORKFORCE-
CALIFORNIA LOST I THINK OVER
HALF A MILLION JOBS AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF NAFTA- WE LEARNED A
LOT FROM NAFTA THERE WERE
SUBSIDIES THE WENT TO PLACE A
LOT OF TALK ABOUT JOB
RETRAINING- RETRAINING- YOU KNOW. MULTI GENERATIONS OF- MANAGED
. BLUE COLLAR. INTO YOU KNOW
CALL CENTER. AND THINGS THAT
MORE OF THOSE JOBS- THAT- SOME.
I WOULD NOT- ANYTHING LIKE THE
JOBS THEY HAD BEFORE DISAPPEARED
WHEN THE FEDERAL SUBSIDIES THAT.
SO WE HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
HISTORY HERE- WE HAVE A HUGE
BLUE COLLAR WORKFORCE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS
PROUD. TO BE CALIFORNIA'S BLUE
COLLAR WORKFORCE PROUD TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA MOVING. AND AT THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES WE ARE A
100% EHIND THOSE WORKERS AND WE
INTEND TO KEEP THEM IN THE JOBS
THEY HAVE AND TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL INDUSTRIAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR MEMBERSHIP. THANK YOU I'M I HAVE JUST ADD
A COUPLE QUESTIONS AND THEN I'LL
OPEN IT OUT TO OTHER MEMBERS. AT
SU. AND ANY OF YOU CAN SPEAK TO
THIS OP HOW MANY. WORKERS ARE
EMPLOYED ON THE PLATFORMS. ON
OFFSHORE OIL PLATFORMS THAT ARE
IN STATE WATERS AND HOW MANY
WORKERS WERE IMPACTED BY THE
DECOMMISSIONING OF HOLIDAY.
LISTEN. EIGHT INDIFFERENTLY HOW
MANY BUILDING BUILDING TRADES
MEMBERS YES. THE BUILDING TRADES
AREN'T TRADITIONALLY ON THE
PLATFORM- THEY DO SOME WORK-
AROUND INSTALLING- PLATFORM
FACILITIES- THE I THINK THAT THE
MORE TIME CALIFORNIAN NICE JOB
BASE YOU WHICH STATE IS IN THE-
YOU KNOW ON SHORING OF IT- AND-
I THINK TYSON I'M PACING YOU
WORKED ON A PLATFORM RIGHT. YES
I DID A LOT OF. YEAH CAN YOU
GUYS HEAR ME YES YEAH SO LONG OF
MADAM IT- I ACTUALLY STARTED MY
CAREER SHORTLY AFTER MY BASEBALL
CAREER ON PLATFORM HOLY I WAS
WORKING FOR THE DRAWING OUT THE
COMPANY CALLED THE NIGHT DRAWING
WE WERE WORKING FOR MEDICAL WHO
WAS THE OPERATOR PLATFORM HOLLY
AT THE TIME. DURING MY TENURE
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE FOR
TWO YEARS ARE WE EMPLOYED ABOUT
FORTY FIVE RATE WORKERS DENTICLE
HAD ABOUT FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FULL
TIME OPERATIONS AND SALARY
EMPLOYEES THAT MANDATE PRODUCED
OIL FROM THE REXALL A
SUBSTANTIAL JOB LOSS FROM THAT
PLATFORM WAS THE COMMISSION.
QUESTION I GUESS OUR CONCERN IS-
SORRY. NOT SPECIFICALLY I MEAN
WE WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE JOB OF
ANY WORKER- THAT IS- YOU KNOW
KIND OF BEING LOST BEFORE ITS
TIME- I THINK THAT. MOREOVER
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GENERAL POLICIES TO STOP- THE
DEVELOPMENT OF YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA BASED- ENERGY. YOU
KNOW AND THE WAY THAT THIS
MIDEAST POLICIES HAVE KIND OF
BLED INTO EACH OTHER SO I THINK
WELL WHEN. YOU'RE TALKING
SPECIFICALLY TODAY MAYBE ABOUT
THOSE JOBS THAT WILL BE LOST ON
THE PLATFORM'S POTENTIALLY WE
ARE ALSO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW THAT POLICY LEADS OVER AND
HOW EXISTING- POLICIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
THREATENING THE JOBS OF HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S
A WILL AND GAS INDUSTRY- YOU
KNOW IS IN A IS IN A POSITION
BECAUSE OF POLICIES- WE'RE
INVESTMENT- AND YOU KNOW FURTHER
INNOVATION IS BEING DISCOURAGED. BECAUSE OF LEGISLATIVE
POLICIES. AND I WOULD WOULD SAY
I MEAN I AND I DON'T THINK I'M
ALONE IN THIS VIEW- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY MICHAEL AS A
POLICYMAKERS TO ENSURE THAT. AS
WE ARE TRANSITIONING CALIFORNIA
TO CLEANER AND GREENER SOURCES
OF ENERGY WE DO SO IN A WAY THAT
BOTH MAINTAINS OUR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND ALSO. INVEST IN
THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES WHICH
OPEN NEW WINDOWS OF OPPORTUNITY
ASK FOR OUR EXISTING WORKFORCE
AND FOR THE WITH THE WORKFORCE
OF THE FUTURE- BUT I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT IS A- VERY
BIG AND LOFTY GOAL. AND THAT WE
NEED DETAILS PLANS AND IN ORDER
TO ACTUALLY MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARDS THAT GOAL AND- WE KNOW
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO ACHIEVE
THAT. AT TRANSITION. IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY WITHOUT.
PLANNING FOR IT- AND SO YOU KNOW
IN MY VIEW THAT IS WHY IT'S SO
CRITICAL FOR US. TO ALL BE
ENGAGED IN THIS CONVERSATION
RIGHT NOW SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT WE'RE MAKING THE RIGHT
INVESTMENTS RIGHT NOW AND THAT
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT PATH
LOOKS LIKE- YEP RATHER THAN JUST
LET IT SNEAK UP ON ICE AND I
FIND OURSELVES IN A POSITION
WHERE. YOU HAVE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
SCREWED OVER AS A RESULT I'M SO
. MISTER GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ONE OF- FOLLOWING THAT SAME
LINE OF- OF CONVERSATION I WANT
TO THANK AARON ALSO TIM AND ALSO
TYSON- FOR YOUR TESTIMONIES HERE
TO DAY OUT- CERTAINLY ARE RIGHT
HERE YOU SEE A SUPPORT YOU I
THINK WE REALLY HAVE TO HAVE I
JUST WANT THIS IS TALKING ABOUT
DECOMMISSIONING- ABANDONED
WELLS- AND I THINK THAT'S ABOUT
WHERE I WAS TALK TO MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER BLOOM THAT THAT WELL THAT
YES LIFE IS INDEED. AND SO IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY THAT DOESN'T-
CAUSES THE ENVIRONMENT TO BE
EXPOSED- THE SITUATION IT TOOK
PLACE YOU KNOW AND ORANGECOUNTY
AREASOFF THE OFF OUR SHORES
HERE HOPEFULLY WE PUT A PLAN IN
PLACE THAT THAT IS NOT WRITTEN
THAT IT IS PUT MEASURES IN PLACE
THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS CAN
NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN MOVING
FORWARD AT THE SAME TIME I AM
VERY MINDFUL. OF THE STATE.
WHERE YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO
PHASE OUT FOSSIL FUEL AND TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT IS DONE IN A-
RESPONSIBLE- AND THOUGHTFUL WAY.
I'M ALSO REMINDED OF A QUOTE
FROM A GENTLEMAN WHO I SERVE
WITH- HE SAID DO YOU WANT TO
SAVE THE CHERY- THE PERSON UNDER
THE TREE. LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN
DO WE SAVE THE SRI OF THE PERSON
UNDER THE TREE AND I MEAN NO
DISRESPECT ANYONE. IS JUST
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE TO COME TO
GRIPS WITH BASED ON. WHERE I
REPRESENT. I REPRESENT PEOPLE.
AND THOSE PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE
JOBS THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES- AND
THEN THOSE WHO ARE IN PRISON WHO
ARE GETTING OUT OF PRISON. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STREETS ARE SAFE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE A SECOND CHANCE
ON LIFE. AND SOME COMPANIES AND
SOME FLOORS ONE EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE THEM BECAUSE
OF THEIR PASS IT IS REGRETTABLE
AND WE TRY TO MAKE POLICIES. SO
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS WON'T BE
DISCRIMINATED ON THAT PASSED THE
BIGGER RIGHT A NEW NARRATIVE
MOVING FORWARD. AND WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT YOU KNOW THIS
CONVERSATION A VERY THOUGHTFUL
MANNER- AGAIN THE END OF LIFE
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO THESE OIL
WELLS. THE OIL WELLS IS NOT
PRODUCING IT'S AWAIT THE
DECOMMISSIONING. POURING THE
CEMENT OF CONCRETE WHATEVER YOU
WANNA CALL IT BECAUSE IT'S OUT
OF COMMISSION. BUT WE ALSO
MOVING FORWARD HAVE TO REALIZE
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT I
ONCE WORKED THERE NEED TO FIND
WORK. AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT. PEOPLE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GET A JOB TO SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES MOVING FORWARD. AND
SO AS I JUST CONCLUDE BY SIMPLY
SAYING THAT. AS WE HAVE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS AND DEBATES BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE DO. THAT'S ALL
RISK OUR RESPONSIBILITY DEBATE
AND MAKE IT INTO DECISION. THAT
WE SHOULD MAKE A DECISION BY
KEEP IN MIND OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WE SERVE AND THE PEOPLE WHO EVEN
WE DON'T SERVE. BUT PEOPLE WHO
WANT PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
CLOTHES. ON THAT USES BACK IN
YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES WHETHER
SAFE AND I BELIEVE IF YOU GIVE A
MAN A WOMAN A JOB WHICH HAS
BEEN. ILLUSTRATED BY THE
TESTIMONY. EITHER OF- TÌM OR
TYSON I GETTING CONFUSED AS WELL
AS A FORMER BASEBALL PLAYER AND
THE OTHER WASN'T BUT NONE THE
LESS ROOM. CHANGING THEIR LIVES
BY GETTING A JOB. FATHER WILL
EASE IN A HOME BOY BAKER TO GIVE
A MAN A WOMAN A JOB. USE YOU
STOP A BULLET. I NEED TO STOP
OPEN BOTH MY COMMUNITY. I NEED
TO STOP THE VIOLENCE THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE AND I'LL BE
INTERESTING HIS JOB IS NOT THE
ANSWER THE ART OF THE AUNT TO
ANSWER ALL THE PROBLEMS BUT IT'S
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEONE RIGHT
NEW NARRATIVE FOR THEM FOR
THEMSELVES AND CHANGE THEIR
THINKING. AND SO AS WE HAVE THIS
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION THAT WE
SHOULD DEBATE IT TRULY BUT HAVE
A THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION BY
CREATING A ALANCE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLAN I'LL BE
QUICK AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS FROM MY- FRIEND
FROM CARSON- BUT I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT- I LIKE THE ANALOGY OF
YOU KNOW THE TREE VERSUS THE
PERSON UNDER THE TREE HOWEVER-
OUR DECISION MAKING IN THIS
REGARD IT IT'S NOT BINARY IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE BINARY WE
HAVE TO STE WE HAVE TO. SAVE THE
TREE AND THE PERSON UNDER THE
TREE AND THAT'S REALLY- WHAT THE
GREAT CHALLENGES- IN
ENVIRONMENTALISM AND UNDERSTAND
THE ECO SYSTEMS- YOU KNOW YOU.
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT SAVING A HUMAN
IF YOU DON'T SAVE THE TREES
CORRECT WE NEED EVERYTHING- TO
BE PRESERVED IT'S HARD WORK- AND
EVER EVER EVERYTHING YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT I THINK IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN. YEAH I
DON'T WANNA KEEP BEATING THE
TREE ANALOGY BUT THERE THERE'S
SOME FOLKS IN THE HE DOES IT'S
IN MY COMMUNITY THAT WOULD GIVE
SOME TREES- WHAT I REALLY WANNA
APPRECIATE. OF THE BUILDING
TRADES COMING TODAY BECAUSE YOU
KNOW I COME FROM THE SCHOOL OF
THOUGHT NOTHING ABOUT US WITHOUT
US. AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE
. INTO A GREEN FUTURE WITHOUT
THE BUILDING TRADES THE IDEA
THAT SOMEBODY'S TRAINED. TO BE
INDUSTRIAL WANTS TO WORK. IN THE
FIELD AT THE WORKING AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ALL CHOSE.
THIS OCCUPATION FOR THE VERY
SAME REASON YOU TAKE PRIDE IN
WHAT YOU DO YOU FIND FULFILLMENT
IN IN THE FACT THAT YOU CAN FEED
YOUR FAMILIES. IS SOMETHING NOT
TO BE. NEGATED I WOULD LOVE
FIRST TO SEE THIS CONVERSATION
MOVED FROM. KINDOF AN
ADVERSARIAL TABLE TO TALK TO ONE
OF INCLUSION- AND I WANT TO
THANK THE BUILDING TRADES FOR
HAVING BEEN A PART OF THAT.
INCLUDES OF CONVERSATION TO THIS
POINT WE WOULDN'T BE A LEADER ON
CLIMATE CHANGE IF IT WASN'T FOR.
THE PEOPLE IN THE WORKING
INDUSTRY THAT HAVE MADE. THE
JUST TRANSITION IN A NUMBER OF
SECTORS ALREADY. AND SO AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE IN INNOVATION.
I GUESS MY QUESTION. BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO JUST SIT UP HERE
AND PONTIFICATE. ABOUT MY
QUESTION FOR THE BUILDING TRADES
AS WE CONTINUE TO BUILD THESE
TABLES OF CONVERSATION OF HOW TO
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER. MAKE SURE
FOLKS CONTINUE TO GET PAID TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE INNOVATE. IS
THAT A TABLE OF THE TO BE
WILLING TO SIT AT BECAUSE I'VE
GOT. MULTIPLE SEATS FOR YOU IF
pPANELISTS ERIN STILL THERE I
WILL IT WILL BE THERE OKAY WILL
BE THERE. I THANK YOU FOR THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE HAVE A WE
HAVE WE HAVE BEEN SAVING THE
TREE AND THE PERSON AS WE FELT
THAT ALL THE SOLAR AND WIND
FIELD- WE'RE UP TO DEATH AT THE
STATE OF MIND THAT WE CAN DO
BOTH BECAUSE WE HAVE- BEEN DOING
BOTH. SIDES I APPRECIATE- MISTER
GIBSON'S ANALOGY. THE BY MAY
THIRTY SOMETHING YES PLEASE.
THIS IS TYSON BAGI JUST GOT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON. THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENTS ARE MET YOU
SOMETIME AGO. IN SACRAMENTO BOB
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT. SOMETHING I HOPE YOU
GUYS UNDERSTAND TOO AS I KNOW
WE'RE DISCUSSING. THE PLATFORMS
BUT I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND THE
MULTIPLIERS THAT AFFECT THOSE
PLATFORMS. WE TAKE OUT OIL
PRODUCING PLATFORMS OR DRILLING
WELLS IN CALIFORNIA. WE TAKE OUT
THE REFINERIES IN THE QUAKE IN
THE EQUATION. A LIVING EXAMPLE
RIGHT NOW AS WE SPEAK. I HAVE
OVER SEVENTY FIVE MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN THE SKILLED
WORKERS. IN OVER A HUNDRED IN
THE BUILDING TRADES AFFECTED BY
ANIMAL THE REFINERY PLANT
CLOSURE. THAT RELY ON THE
EXXONMOBIL. OFF PLATFORM. TO
SUPPLY ITS TRUE OR- PEOPLE GONE
THOSE JOBS ARE GONE BOTH LIVING
CAREERS THAT THEY HAD. FOR THE
LAST TWENTY TO THIRTY YEARS IS
NOW OVER LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
TRANSFER TO OTHER FACILITIES
WHEN THEY HAD A GOOD WORKING
FACILITY THERE. BUT THE
LEGISLATOR FAILED FAILED TO HELP
RESTORE THAT PIPELINE TO GET
CRUDE FLOWING TO THAT FACILITY
WHICH IMPACTED NOT ONLY
CALIFORNIA JOBS. WHAT IMPACT THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENT DUE TO
TRANSFERRING AND THE OVER FOOD
PRODUCTION MAKE UP THAT WE HAD.
ON THANK YOU AND TO ADD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH THANK YOU-
THIS QUESTION COULD IT COULD BE
FOR AARON TYSON ATTEMPT SO WE'VE
BEEN HEARING A LOT ABOUT
TRANSITION AND HOW IT LOOKS LIKE
BUT FROM I WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU
WHETHER IT BE JOB RETAINING OR
GUARANTEED INCOME HOW DOES IT
LOOK LIKE FOR YOUR WORKFORCE.
ERIN IF I MAY START OFF ON THAT
PLEASE- I'D LIKE TO. ANSWER THAT
QUESTION SO I'VE I'VE HEARD THAT
TERM A LOT RIGHT JUST TRANSITION
. WHAT I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE'RE
NOT INTERESTED IN HERE TO
SKILLED WORKERS LOCAL THREE
TWENTY SIX IS A CORPORATE
WELFARE PROGRAM. WE HAVE ABLE
BODIED WILLING PEOPLE TO WORK. I
WANT TO SHOW YOU GUYS I HOPE
THAT YOU DO SOME RESEARCH AFTER
THIS TO LOOK AT THE RODEO RENEW
PROJECT HERE FOR PHILLIPS SIXTY
SIX. WERE ACTUALLY INVESTING THE
COMPANY IS INVESTING ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
CURRENT FACILITY. THAT ALL
EMPLOYEES ARE CURRENTLYFULL
TIME WORKFORCE BUT OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED TRADESMEN AND WOMEN TO
COME IN THERE AND BUILD THIS
STATE OF THE ART FACILITY. THAT
IS AN EXAMPLE OF TRUST JUST
TRANSITION MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS OUT OF LOCAL FIVE U. S.
W. AT THE MARATHON MARTINEZ
REFINERY. DID NOT GET TO
EXPERIENCE THAT. THEY HAD OVER A
75% REDUCTION WORK FORCE TO THE
CONVERSION OF RENEWABLE FACILITY
PHILLIPS SIXTY SIX HAS BEEN A
CLASS ACT AND THROWN HIM. AND I
ONLY KEEP THE CURRENT WORKFORCE
BUT EXPAND IT. AND KEEP OUR
ENERGY JOBS ARE HELPING
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION AND OBTAIN
THE AGGRESSIVE. QUALITY GOALS
SET BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM. AND YES
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HIGH.
THAT EXAMPLE- ALSO YOUR COMMENTS
YOU S. TO. AS MANY THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND EMERGING.
INDUSTRIES INCLUDING AND
HYDROGEN AND CARBON CAPTURE
WHERE THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR US TO NOT JUST RETAIN THE
JOBS THAT WE HAVE THAT CREATE
MORE AND BETTER JOBS- AND SO I
THINK IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE- ALL CONTINUE. NOT IN
NOT IN THAT CONVERSATION AND
SURE THAT WE ARE MAKING THE
RIGHT INCENTIVE AT MAKING RIGHT
INVESTMENTS IN THE RIGHT POLICY
DECISIONS IN ORDER TO
INCENTIVIZE THAT ACT KIND OF
GROWTH INNOVATION. AND
OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA- WITH
THAT THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT AND
WE'VE HAD TO SORRY WE HAD TO
FIGHT- THE SAME ACTIVISTS- THAT
ARE YOU KNOW. HAMMERING THE
EXISTING ENERGY INDUSTRY TO
ENTITLE OF THE SOLAR FIELDS AND
WIND FARMS AND WE'RE FINDING THE
SAME THING AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH OFFSHORE WIND YOU KNOW THE
GREAT. HORIZON FOR ADDITIONAL
GREEN- POWER TO BE BROUGHT INTO
ON SHORE AND TO CALIFORNIA BUT
WE HAVE WE ARE SPENDING SO MUCH
OF OUR TIME COLLECTIVELY TRYING
TO FIGHT TO BRING ADDITIONAL
GREEN POWER ON TO BRING CLEAN
FUEL TO MARKET. DID YOU ALL OF
THE THINGS WILL CREATE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
COLLECTIVE MEMBERSHIP. SO AS FAR
AS LIKE THE LEGISLATURE LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO HELP THIS
INDUSTRIAL- WORKFORCE TO
CONTINUE TO DO WHAT THEY DO. AND
HIS WORK IT'S THE LISTING UP
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES IT'S LOOKING
AT WAYS THAT WE CAN STREAMLINED
I THINK TYSON TOUCHED ON THAT IN
THE BEGINNING. THE AMOUNT OF RED
TAPE THERE IS TO DO THE THINGS
THAT ACTUALLY MOVE THAT THE
AGENDA IN CALIFORNIA FORWARD
LIKE LET'S THINK OF WAYS THAT WE
CAN COLLECTIVELY. THREE MINUTE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES BOTH TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A GREENER PLACE AND
ALSO TO CREATE INDUSTRIAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OURMEMBERS
AND THE NEXT GENERATION OF KIDS
THAT YOU KNOW THE CAMPS OUT
THERE RECRUITING ON A DAILY
BASIS FROM THE MILITARY- YOU
KNOW RECENTLY INCARCERATED- KIDS
FROM THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE BUILDING
TRADES TO THAT'S WHICH CAN DOES.
ALL DAY EVERY DAY. THANK YOU.
WILL PROBABLY NOT I DO BELIEVE I
THEIR OWN. CON LET IN THE S. OF
A HUNDRED TWENTY MEMBERS. ONLY A
HANDFUL OF US THAT ACTUALLY
SIGNED A FRONT OF A CHECK IN
EMPLOYED PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA I
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE POLICIES
DO IN THE STATE TO KILL A
BUSINESS. BECAUSE I CLOSE MINE
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN BECAUSE
OF THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
WE'RE GOING AFTER THE OIL
INDUSTRY PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET RIGHT HERE'S TO PHASE OUT
THE OIL INDUSTRY. THEY'RE GOING
AFTER YOUR JOBS AND THEN WE SIT
HERE TALK ABOUT JOBS THAT WE
WANT TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA. AND
WE WANT TO BE PUBLIC SAFETY. BUT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THAT THE
FUNDING OF THE COPS WE CAN'T
HAVE IT BOTH WAYS FOLKS. WE NEED
TO KEEP THEIR JOBS IN CALIFORNIA
IT QUIT GOING AFTER THE
INDUSTRIES. TO CREATE THOSE JOBS
IF THE OIL INDUSTRY THE AIRLINE
INDUSTRY THE FOREST INDUSTRY.
THE AUTO INDUSTRY. WE CREATE
POLICIES THAT ARE HAMMERING
THESE BUSINESSES. THEY LEAVE THE
STATE. OIL INDUSTRY'S GOING TO
LOUISIANA GOING TO TEXAS GOING
TO THE EAST COAST. AND WE
IMPORTED OIL. WE DON'T CUT DOWN
THE FORCED TO CREATE OUR LUMBER
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
BUT IT BURNS UP IN THIS STATE BY
MILLIONS OF ACRES EVERY YEAR. I
CAN RAIL AND I CAN RAIL BUT WE
HAVE TO GET BACK INTO THE
POLICIES THAT CREATE JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. NOT KILL JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AND I MISS
DAVIES THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT-
QUICK QUESTION- ERIN A NUMBER OF
UNIONS AND TRADE GROUPS SIGNED
ON AND DEVELOP THE A CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE JOB PLANS WHICH
PREVIEWED SOME OF THE POLICIES-
NEEDS FOR POTENTIAL TRANSITION
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUEL JOBS.
HOWEVER THE BUILDING TRADES DID
NOT SIGN ON I'M CURIOUS WHY WAS
THAT AND WHAT PLAN LACKED OR IS
MISSING THAT WE ARE NOT
CONSIDERING WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
WORKFORCE IMPACT. I JUST WANNA
MAKE A GROUP QUICK POINTS WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE TREE IN THE
PERSON OR THE TREE. WE TALK
ABOUT STOPPING TAKING THESE JOBS
AWAY BY TRANSITIONING TO OTHERS
WELL IF YOU LOOK AT COVERT RIGHT
NOW WE'VE GOT SO MANY JOB
OPENINGS RIGHT NOW UP AND YET
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE ON UNEMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE THESE AREN'T THE JOBS
THEY WANT SO. JUST CONSIDERING
THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE THESE JOBS
AWAY BUT YOU'RE GOING TO WANT
THIS JOB ISN'T EXACTLY TRUE. AND
SO I THINK THAT AGAIN WE NEED TO
REALIZE THIS IS WHAT THEY TRAIN
FOR THIS IS WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
AND TO TAKE THIS WAY THING NOW
OR HERE YOU GO YOU'RE NOT GONNA
BECOME THIS. IS JUST NOT
REALISTIC AGAIN WE'RE WATCHING
THIS BUT CALL BUT PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING BACK TO WORK TO CERTAIN
JOBS THAT THEY HAD OR JOBS THAT
ARE OPENING THEIR THEY DON'T
WANT THOSE JOBS EVEN THOUGH THEY
ARE UNEMPLOYED AT THIS POINT.
YOU'RE IN IF YOU DON'T MIND-
RESPONDING TO THAT QUESTION I
APPRECIATE IT. SURE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF FALLACY. YOU
KNOW JOB RETRAINING. THIS NOTION
OF THE JOB RETRAINING- AND YOU
KNOW. THAT WE CAN IF THERE'S A
KIND OF A- PROBLEM THAT MONEY
CAN SOLVE. AS FAR AS- IF YOU'LL
JUST RETRAIN FOLKS THEY WILL
TAKE THOSE JOBS. AND AGAIN IT
GOES BACK TO IT YOU KNOW. AT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THAT I
REALLY- RESPECT MOST ABOUT THE-
THAT MEN AND WOMEN. THAT WE
REPRESENT IS THE PRIDE THEY TAKE
IN THEIR WORK- JUST LIKE I
ASSUME ALL OF YOU DO- YOU KNOW.
GROWING UP THIS WAS- THIS WAS
THE END GAME. FOR THE MEN AND
WOMEN IT WASN'T A DEFAULT
PROFESSION IT WAS A TRADE THAT.
THAT TOOK. YEARS FOR THEM TO
MASTER- THEY GO TO. THEIR
APPRENTICE PROGRAM- WAS MUCH
HARDER. THAN MY YOU KNOW COLLEGE
AND LAW SCHOOL EDUCATION I COULD
NOT HAVE HAPPENED MAYBE I
COULD'VE BUT- I COULD. ACT A LOT
OF. THE TRAINING THAT THESE GUYS
GO THROUGH IT IS. DAY AND NIGHT.
THEY WORK AND THEY GO TO SCHOOL
FULL TIME AT THE SAME TIME IT IS
AN INTENTIONAL PROFESSION- AND
THEY DON'T WANT. TO DO. SO I
THINK. THAT AND MISSED YOU KNOW
UNQUOTE JOSH. AND THEN LET'S
TALK ABOUT JOB REACH FOR. IS IT
SOME A CO OF SAN. THAT THAT YOU
KNOW THESE GUYS WHEN I SAY GUYS
IT'S NOT A WAY WILL TAKE. YOU
KNOW WHATEVER IS. TO THEM. WELL
THAT'S THAT'S JUST NOT TRUE THEY
WANT TO DO WITH JOB. THEY WERE
TRAINED TO DO AND WANT TO DO
THAT. THAT THEY'RE PROUD TO DO
AND WHEN YOU KNOW. THERE'S EIGHT
HI WITHIN THE BUILDING TRADES
BECAUSE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS GOES HOME AT THE END OF
THE DAY ARE GOES HOME AT THE END
OF SHIPS AND THEY'RE TIRED. AND
DIRTY BUT THEY HAVE BUILT
SOMETHING THEY HAVE MADE IT
SOMETHING. AND THE SENSE OF
CRIED THEY GET FROM THAT IS
NOTHING THAT YOU CAN YOU KNOW BE
TRAINED THEM TO DO- THIS IS
THEIR CHOSEN PROFESSION THIS IS
WHO THEY ARE AND THAT'S HOW THEY
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES. AND I THINK
AS WE GO FORWARD IT'S IMPORTANT
TO GIVE. YOU KNOW THE RISKS
BACK. OF WHAT A TRADE MEANS TO
ANOTHER PERSON AND YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHY WE WERE NOT
INTERESTED COLLECTIVELY IN THIS
SENSE OF YOU KNOW THAT'S GOING
TO PRODUCE JEFF TRANSITION.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW OUR GUYS ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO THE
TRADE BUT THEY WEREN'T THEY
INTENDED TO DO THAT THEY WORK TO
DO THAT THEY TRAINED TO DO AND
THAT THEY DO DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
AND THAT'S HOW THEY SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILY. THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT SAID HOW CAN WE AS
LEGISLATORS SUPPORT OUR WORKERS
BY CREATING. NEW OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE TRADES. ABOUT THREE.
LET'S GET THESE NEW PROCESS
BELT. BUT GET CARBON CAP GOING
LET'S GET. ONLINE LET'S GET NEW
FUEL ONLINE. LET'S BUILD A SURE
WE- I CAN ON. ALL DAY. I'M A WE
DO WE GO BACK TO GOING BACK TO
MISTER GIBSON REDUCING THEM. THE
PERSON UNDER THE AND YOU SAY
THAT YOU. WE HAVE SO MUCH WE CAN
DO A COLLECTIVE. IT WILL RAISE
THE BY AND WE'RE JUST DO THAT
AND IT'S MISSION CREDIT TIME WE
ARE UP TO. IT THERE'S- URGENCY-
THIS STATE DOES NOT HAVE THE
TRANSMISSION- YOU KNOW IT DOES
NOT HAVE THE POWER PRODUCTION
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT. THE THE
GOALS THAT WE SET FOR THE STATE
I MEAN WE NEED TO GET GOING
YESTERDAY. SO STREAMLINING AS
THE WAY TO DO IT WE NEED TO GET
THESE NEW FACILITIES ONLINE. AND
WE NEED TO GET OUR MEMBERS
WORKING ON THESE NEW FACILITIES.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
WHAT YOU DO. THANK YOU. AND YET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS THE
HEY I AND MISTER JEFFRIES MR AT
BANK FOR JOINING US TODAY.
OBVIOUSLY YOU USE IT BEST WE
NEED GET MOVING YESTERDAY ON. ON
OF THAT SAID FOR TO CAN. OUR
THAT CONVERSE. AND HAVE WITH
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO OUR
LAST PANEL WE ALREADY DID THAT
WE SORT OF. TOUCHED ON THE AT
PLATFORM HOLLY. IN PREVIOUS
DISCUSSIONS WERE GONNA SKIP THAT
AND AB MOVE TO OUR FINAL PANEL.
WHICH IS AT RIGS TO REEFS A
VIABLE STRATEGY FOR CALIFORNIA-
AND WE ARE PLEASED TO WELCOME
AMBER SPARKS FROM THE BLUE
LATITUDES FOUNDATION. AND I
THINK WE'LL ALSO BE BRINGING
BACK MISS CROSS I THINK TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. ALONG WITH
THAT MISS PARKS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY. SO I
DO HAVE A PRESENTATION IF YOU
COULD GO TO THE FIRST FIVE. SHE
THOUGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING TOGETHER
THIS HEARING IS AN HONOR TO BE
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS AMBER
SPARKS I AM A MARINE
CONSERVATION BIOLOGIST AND CO
PRESIDENT ON THE BLUE LATITUDES
FOUNDATION OR FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE NON PROFIT THAT WORKS ON
CONSERVATION ISSUES AT THE
INTERSECTION OF INDUSTRY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. I'M ALSO A CO
FOUNDER OF BLUE LATITUDES LOC A
FEDERAL FEDERALLY CERTIFIED
WOMEN OWNED MARINE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSULTING FIRM. THAT'S BEEN
WORKING FOR THE PAST. TEN YEARS
ON. LAKE STREET CONVERSION
PROCESS- PROJECTS AROUND THE
WORLD DOING ECOLOGICAL VALUE
ASSESSMENTS IN THE GULF OF
MEXICO THAILAND MALAYSIA SO I'M
EXCITED TO BE HERE TODAY AND
SHARE SOME OF MY EXPERTISE NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. MY INTEREST IN
RIGS AS REEFS REALLY BEGAN IN
GRADUATE SCHOOL WHERE I WAS A-
SETTING THESE PLATFORMS. AND
BEING ADVISED BY DR MILTON LOVE
. I SCRIPT INSTITUTION OF
OCEANOGRAPHY. WE WERE LOOKING AT
THESE PLATFORMS WHICH FROM ONE
SPEECH SHARE REALLY LOOK LIKE
INDUSTRIAL MENACING GIANTS BUT
WHEN YOU GO BELOW THE SURFACE
THERE IS SO MUCH MORE AND AS
PRODUCTION IS COMING TO AN END
WE REALLY NEED TO ASK THE
QUESTION NEXT SLIDE. OF WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE OIL WELLS DRY
UP. NEXT SLIDE. ENTER THIS
ENGINEERING FEAT OF A LIFETIME
HOW TO REMOVE THE STRUCTURE SOME
THE SIZE OF THE EMPIRE STATE
BUILDING FROM THE SEA FLOOR. AS
WE'VE HEARD FROM PREVIOUS
PRESENTATIONS TODAY THIS PROCESS
OF DECOMMISSIONING CAN BE VERY
TECHNICALLY COMPLEX AND HAVE
SOME SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES AS WELL NEXT SLIDE.
SPECIALLY WHEN WE CONSIDER THAT
BELOW THE SURFACE EVERY BEAM AND
CROSSBEAM OF CALIFORNIANS
PLATFORMS ARE COVERED IN MARINE
LIFE WE SKI SEA SCALLOPS AND
ENEMIES. SCHOOLS OF JACK
MACKEREL NEXT SLIDE. WE EVEN SEE
SOME OF OUR STATE SALTWATER FISH
THAT GARIBALDI THAT NASA MAKE
THEIR PERMANENT HOME ON THESE
OFFSHORE STRUCTURES. NEXT SLIDE. RIGS TO REEF PROVIDES AN
ALTERNATIVE TO COMPLETELY
REMOVING THE POP FROM JACKET
FROM THE WATERCOLUMN IN WHICH
THE STRUCTURE IS MODIFIED SO
THAT IT CAN CONTINUE TO FUNCTION
AS AN ARTIFICIAL REEF. DIRECTORY
OF CONVERSION THE WELL IS GOING
TO BE SEALED AND CAPPED AND THE
OIL COMPANIES WILL RETAIN
LIABILITY FOR THAT WELL IN
PERPETUITY BUT THE PLATFORM
JACKET WHICH TO MEET COAST GUARD
REGULATIONS WOULD BE CUT DOWN
EIGHTY FIVE FEET BELOW THE WATER
SURFACE TO ALLOW FOR SHIPS TO
SAFELY DROPPED OVER. AND NOT
REMAINING PLATFORM JACKET WOULD
REMAIN IN THE WATER COLUMN TO
FUNCTION AS AN ARTIFICIAL REEF
BACKSIDE. BUT BEFORE WE GET TOO
FAR AHEAD OF OURSELVES WHAT
REALLY IS AN ARTIFICIAL REEF.
YOU CAN'T JUST SAY EVERYTHING WE
PUT IN THE OCEAN IS GOING TO
MAKE FOR. GOOD HABITAT NEXT
SLIDE RESEARCHERS HAVE PLACED RE
FALLS ON THE SEA FLOOR TO LOOK
AT HOW MARINE LIFE COLONIZES AND
THEY- LOOK AT COLONIZATION RATES
AND USE A SAYS THE STUDY POINT
NEXT LINE. ARTISTS EVEN HAVE
THEIR OWN TAKE BY. LOOKING AT
HOW THEIR INSTALLATIONS ON THE
SEA FLOOR CAN BE ENHANCED BY.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF MARINE LIFE
NEXT SLIDE. BUT WHAT MAKES AN
OIL PLATFORM A GOOD CANDIDATE
FOR AN ARTIFICIAL REEF NOW THIS
SICK REALLY LIES IN THE
STRUCTURE ITSELF FROM SEA FLOOR
TO SEE SERVICE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
REAL ESTATE. AND COMPLEXITY WITH
THE STRUCTURES BEAMS AND CROSS
BEAMS THAT ATTRACT MARINE LIFE
THESE PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN
STUDIED HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS AND HAVE BEEN
FOUND TO BE AT SOME OF THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE MARINE HABITATS ON
THE PLANET. NEXT SLIDE. BUT
CALIFORNIA IS NOT THE ONLY PLACE
WHERE THEY'RE OFF THROWINGGAS
PLATFORMS NEXT SLIDE. AND SO I'D
LIKE TO SHOW A QUICK. VIDEO OF
RICK'S REEF PROGRAMS AROUND THE
WORLD HERE SEE A MAP OF THE
GLOBE IN THE RED AND- THE RED
AND BLUE REPRESENTS OIL AND GAS
FIELDS. AS YOU CAN SEE THE
FIELDS ARE HIGHLY CONCENTRATED
ALONG THE SHORELINE AND
OFFSHORE. IN FACT IN EVERY OCEAN
UP WE ARE EXTRACTING OIL AND GAS
RESERVES. SO WITH THIS
INTERNATIONAL REACH YOU WOULD
THINK THAT DECOMMISSIONING
ALTERNATIVES ARE DECOMMISSIONING
DISCUSSIONS WOULD BE DISCUSSED
ON AN INTERNATIONAL STAGE BUT
THIS IS NOT THE CASE THERE ONLY
A FEW PLACES THAT HAVE. RICK'S
REEF ALTERNATIVE SOMEONE TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WELL
ESTABLISHED AS WELL AS THOSE
THOSE THAT ARE JUST BEGINNING TO
DEVELOP. FIRST WE'LL TAKE A LOOK
AT CALIFORNIA WHERE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN FORMER GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER SIGNED IN AB
TWENTY FIVE OH THREE. THE MARINE
RESOURCE LEGACY ACT WHICH
PERMITS- DECOMMISSIONING OF OUR
PLATFORMS AS POTENTIAL REEFS.
HOWEVER DUE TO SOME OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ISSUES WITHIN THE
LAW IT DOESN'T INCENTIVIZE THE
OIL COMPANIES FOR THE STATE TO
REALLY PARTICIPATE MANY OF THESE
ISSUES ARE WITH THE LIABILITY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE POP FROM
JACKET ITSELF. SO SINCE ITS
SIGNING IN TWO THOUSAND TEN NONE
OF OUR PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN
BRIEFED. NOW THIS STANDS IN
STARK CONTRAST TO THE GULF OF
MEXICO WHERE THE STATES OF.
LOUISIANA AND TEXAS HAVE BEEN
REAPING THEIR PLATFORMS FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS THEY HAVE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN. FIVE HUNDRED AND SIX
HUNDRED PLATFORMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY FUNCTIONING AS
SUCCESSFUL ARTIFICIAL REEFS AND
MANAGED BY THE STATE'S THEIR- IN
THE STATE'S DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. NOW WILL HEAD OVER
TO SOUTHEAST ASIA AND TAKE A
LOOK AT PER NIGHT WHICH HAS
REPURPOSE A STRUCTURE FOR ECO
TOURISM THEY RETROFITTED THE TOP
SIDE SO THAT GUESTS COULD COME
AND STAY THERE AND THEN DIVE IN
THE PLOT FROM JACK IN THE
SURROUNDING REEF THIS IS A
POTENTIAL RE PURPOSING IDEA THAT
HAS WORKED TO GENERATE. MONEY
FOR THE LOCAL ECONOMY HERE OFF
THE COAST OF FOR NINE. OTHER
AREAS IN THE SOUTH CHINA SEA
INCLUDING THE GULF OF THAILAND
HAVE BEGUN TO DEVELOP. THEIR OWN
RIGS TO REEF PROGRAMS OVER THE
PAST TEN YEARS THEY'VE BEEN
RESEARCHING. HOW TO. MAKE A
SUCCESSFUL ROOFING PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDED DISCUSSING THESE
PROGRAMS WITH MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS FISHING
STAKEHOLDERS REGULATORY
STAKEHOLDERS AND- THE GULF OF
THAILAND HAS JUST PASSED THEIR
FIRST. RETHINK CANDIDATE. OUR
LAST STOP WILL BE OFF THE COAST
OF AFRICA IN THE BONE WHERE DR
NICK SALA AND NATIONAL
GEOGRAPHIC EXPLORER WENT AND
BUILT ON THESE PLATFORMS WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT WHILE TRAWLING HAD
DECIMATING THE FISHING
POPULATIONS IN THE SURROUNDING
AREA. THESE PLATFORMS WERE HOT
SPOTS FOR LIFE AND HIS RESEARCH
GOT THESE PLATFORMS INCORPORATED
INTO AFRICA'S LARGEST MARINE
PARK. NEXT SLIDE. NOW I WANT TO
DO A QUICK OVERVIEW OF SOME OF
THE PROS AND CONS OF THIS
PROGRAM NEXT SLIDE. NEXT SLIDE.
FIRST CON WE SEE. AS A LACK OF
GLOBAL LEGISLATION FOR A WHILE.
EVERY STREET PROGRAM IN THE GULF
OF MEXICO MIGHT BE SUCCESSFUL
FOR THE STATE OF TEXAS AND
LOUISIANA WE NEED TO LOOK AT HOW
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL
IN CALIFORNIA AND REALLY.
ADDRESS OUR STAKEHOLDER NEEDS
AND PREFERENCES TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. NEXT SLIDE.
INVASIVE SPECIES IS ANOTHER
CONCERN THIS PHOTO WAS TAKEN. ON
A DIVE ON THE PLOT FROM THE GULF
OF MEXICO THAT'S A LINE FISH
WHICH IS INVASIVE. THERE HAVE
BEEN FOUND TO BE INVASIVE
SPECIES ON CALIFORNIA'S
PLATFORMS AND THEY'VE DONE SOME
RESEARCH ON THIS IN THE GULF OF
MEXICO AND THEY FOUND THAT
WHILE. THE PLATFORMS WERE ACTING
AS A STEPPING STONE FOR THE
SPREAD OF INVASIVE SPECIES THEY
WEREN'T SPREADING AT A RATE ANY
GREATER THAN THE NATURAL NEARBY
BRIEFS. NEXT SLIDE. ANOTHER CON
WE SEE AS A LACK OF PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDING FOR WHEN MOST
PEOPLE SEE OFFER PLATFORMS
UNLESS YOU'RE A DIVER FISHERMAN
YOU. LIKELY HAVE NO IDEA THAT
THERE COULD BE A MARINE
ECOSYSTEM BENEATH THE SURFACE.
THIS IS WHERE A LOT OF OUR WORK
IS REALLY FOCUSED ON
DISSEMINATING THE SCIENCE AND
COMMUNICATING TO THE PUBLIC THE
VALUE OF THE STRUCTURES. AS
ARTIFICIAL REEFS. AND THIS ALSO
WILL HELP THEM TO MAKE. INFORMED
DECISIONS REGARDING THE FUTURE
OF THEIR OCEAN RESOURCES NEXT
SLIDE. ANOTHER CON WE SEE IS IF
THE STRUCTURES ARE PERMANENTLY
INSTALLED AS RE STABLE BE. AN
OBSTRUCTION ON THE SEA FLOOR TO
LIMIT OTHER. OCEAN USERS FROM
ACCESSING THAT SPACE ONE
POTENTIAL CONFLICT COULD ARISE
WITH TROLL FISHERMEN WHO.
TROLLING IS LIKE TAKING A
GIGANTIC NOT THE SIZE OF A
FOOTBALL FIELD AND RUNNING ALONG
THE SEA FLOOR MALIK MAY HAVE
SOME DESTRUCTIVE COMPONENT TO IT
IT IS A VIABLE FISHING INDUSTRY
AND WITH THESE PLATFORMS IN THE
WAY IT THEIR INSTRUCTION TO THAT
PARTICULAR FISHERY. NEXT SLIDE.
NOW TAKE A QUICK LOOK AT SOME OF
THE PROS AND THE POTENTIAL FOR
THE STRUCTURES TO ENHANCE OUR
LOCAL FISHERIES NEXT SLIDE
ESPECIALLY AS OUR- NEXT SLIDE.
ESPECIALLY AS OUR NEARSHORE
HABITATS ARE DEGRADED BY. RUNOFF
POLLUTION OVERFISHING WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS THAT MANY SPECIES ARE
MOVING OFF SHORE AND MAKING
THEIR PERMANENT HOME ON THESE
PLATFORMS NEXT SLIDE. ANOTHER
PRO WE SEE IS THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED
HERE TODAY THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH DECOMMISSIONING. IF A
STRUCTURE IS REACHED THERE WILL
BE A SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS
AND- ACCORDING TO AB TWENTY FIVE
OH THREE A PORTION OF THAT
SAVINGS WOULD GO BACK TO THE
STATE INTO AN ENDOWMENT FOR
MARINE PRESERVATION AND
CONSERVATION NEXT SLIDE. IN FACT
IF TWENTY THREE OF CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY SEVEN PLATFORMS WERE
REMOVED THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD GET 600-528-0050 MILLION.
AS PART OF A TOTAL ONE BILLION
AND SAVE COSTS. EXCITED. WE HAVE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AT BLUE
LATITUDE FOUNDATION DOT ORG
HANDPRINT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
REACH OUT TO ME- VIA VIA MY
EMAIL AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH YOU ALL ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT CONSERVATION ISSUE.
THANK YOU AT QUESTIONS. I HAVE I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS TO
AND WE EVER HEARD THAT THE REEFS
THAT'S RIGHT THE RAGS OF
CALIFORNIA'S COAST ARE IN WATER
I THINK IT'S YOU KNOW FROM
THIRTY EIGHT FEET TO TWELVE
HUNDRED FEET DEEP- SUIT WHAT ARE
THE CRITERIA THAT MAKE A RAKE
SUITABLE FOR YOU KNOW EVEN
CONSIDERING THIS THIS KIND OF
THING. ARE THERE CERTAIN DEPTH
REQUIREMENTS- ARE THERE ANY
LIMITATIONS TO WHAT KIND OF A
RIG COULD ACTUALLY BE
APPROPRIATE FOR ROOFING
ABSOLUTELY SO. EVERY PLATFORM
NEEDS TO BE AT. LOOKED AT ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS AND WATER
DEPTH PLAYS. PLAYS IN
SIGNIFICANTLY HERE ESPECIALLY IF
WE NEED TO- IT HERE TO THE U. S.
COAST CARDS REGULATION OF HAVING
AT CUT OFF DEPTH OF EIGHTY FIVE
FEET. OBVIOUSLY THE PLATFORMS IN
SHALLOWER WATERS ARE NOT GOING
TO BE. A GREAT CANDIDATE
COMPLEXITY IS ANOTHER. MAJOR
COMPONENT A STRUCTURE THAT IS
MORE COMPLEX WILL LIKELY HAVE
MORE NOOKS AND CRANNIES AREAS
FOR MARINE LIFE THAT TO DEVELOP.
AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER CRITICAL
COMPONENT THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT- IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF OUR
PLATFORMS HAVE BURNED STALLED
DECADES AGO AND SO THEIR
TECHNICAL CONSIDERATIONS AS WELL
IN TERMS OF HOW WE CAN FEASIBLY
REMOVE THAT STRUCTURE AND WHERE
ARE WE GOING TO BRING IT ON
SHORE OR DISMANTLE IT IN ANOTHER
AREA SO THOSE ARE ALL
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT. AND SO THAT THE- TWENTY
SEVEN PLATFORMS- IN IN
CALIFORNIA WATERS. DO YOU HAVE
AN ASSESSMENT ON AROUND HIM HOW
MANY OF THOSE MIGHT BE SUITABLE
FOR ROOFING. WE HAVE NOT DONE AN
ASSESSMENT ON HOW MANY WOULD BE
A SUITABLE FOR ROOFING BUT THERE
ARE MANY THAT WOULD BE
APPLICABLE CANDIDATES. YES I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE TWENTY THREE
AND FEDERAL WATERS AND AS YOU GO
FURTHER OFF SHORE IT YOU GAIN
GREATER AND GREATER DEATH
WRITTEN SO THOSE COULD BE
POTENTIALLY. GOOD CANDIDATES.
AND I THINK WE HAVE I'M MISS
CRAP. ON FOR THIS PANEL AS WELL
. I KNOW YOU MENTIONED SOME OF
THIS IN YOUR PRESENTATION AS
WELL I DO YOU HAVE A PET HAVE
YOU OR YOUR ORGANISATION DONE AN
ASSESSMENT AROUND. I DON'T WHAT
PLATFORMS IN FEDERAL AT SORRY IN
CALIFORNIA WATERS WOULD
POTENTIALLY BE SUITABLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WHAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT IS- THE CRITERIA THAT
ARE ESTABLISHED IN THE STATE
LAW- SO THESE HAVEN'T BEEN
APPLIED YET BUT THE CRITERIA
REQUIRE- THE STATE TO CONSIDER
THE DEPTH OF THE PLATFORM THE
LOCATION OF THE PLATFORM AND
PROXIMITY TO OTHER REEFS- TO
LOOK AT POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO
BIOLOGICAL RESOURCES AND WATER
QUALITY FOR FULL REMOVAL VERSUS
PARTIAL REMOVAL. LOOK AT
POTENTIAL BENEFITS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT A FULL VERSUS
PARTIAL REMOVAL- LOOK AT THE
CONTRIBUTION TO PRODUCTIVITY OF
FICTION WRITING LIFE AND FINALLY
TO LOOK AT POTENTIAL MANAGEMENT
RESTRICTIONS SUCH AS DEALING
WITH FISHING- ON THE STRUCTURES
SO AFTER ALL THAT ANALYSIS IS
DONE THE STATE IS REQUIRED ON
THE PLATFORM BY PLATFORM BASIS
TO DETERMINE WHICH OPTION
PROVIDES THE NET BENEFIT TO THE
RATE ENVIRONMENT- I AGREE WITH
DESPITE THAT- THE SHOWER
PLATFORM PROBABLY DON'T EVEN
QUALIFY BECAUSE OF THE
NAVIGATIONAL REQUIREMENTS BUT- I
THINK THE TAKEAWAY HERE IS THAT
WE'RE EMBARKING ON THAT PROCESS-
HOLLY WILL BE THE FIRST PLATFORM
BUT THERE'S- EIGHT. IN THE QUEUE
NOW WE THINK THAT NUMBER WILL
INCREASE PRETTY DRAMATICALLY
GIVEN THAT MOST OF THE PLATFORMS
OFFER CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
PRODUCING VERY MUCH- AND- ARMIES
OF SCALE WILL MAKE THE- MORE
FOR- ONE. THE COMPANIES COULD-
JOINT. INSURANCE OF THE CALL
WORKS ONE THE LARGEST COSTS OF
DECOMMISSIONING IS BRING IN THE
RESOLVER FROM THE NORTH SEA-
THAT'S BEEN IMPEDIMENT. BUT NOW
THEY CAN SHARE THOSE COSTS AND
SO WE THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THAT NUMBER GO UP WE'RE GONNA
YOU HAVE THESE ANALYSES I'M AS
WELL AS THE ENVIRONMENT REVIEW
SO I THINK WE'RE ON OUR WAY- AND
THEN WE'LL- FIND OUT WHICH
PLATFORMS. ARE APPROPRIATE- TO
BE- PARTIALLY REMOVED AND WHICH
ARE MORE APPROPRIATE TO BE FULLY
REMOVED. AND I SUIT THE EX
MARINE CALIFORNIA'S MARINE
RESOURCES LEGACY ACT- WE SPACE
PASSED IN TWENTY TEN IN AT LEAST
IN CONCEPT ESTABLISHED TO RIGS
TO REEF. FRAMEWORK FOR
CALIFORNIA- IS YOU BOTH
MENTIONED IN YOUR REMARKS THAT.
HAS NOT RESULTED IN ANY. OF
THESE PLATFORMS ACTUALLY BEING
RECEIVED I'M REALLY INTERESTED
IN BOTH OF YOUR PERSPECTIVES-
ROUND OUT WHY THAT'S THAT HAS
BEEN THE CASE. AND IF THERE ARE
APPROPRIATE- MODIFICATIONS TO
THAT OR IF THERE ARE MARK
MODIFICATIONS TO THAT FACT THAT
YOU BELIEVE WOULD BE APPROPRIATE. WELL I CAN YEAH I THINK THAT.
IS AREALLY SIMPLE ANSWER WHICH
AT JUNE GENERAL CASEY MENTION.
THE STATE CANNOT FORCE THE
COMPANY TO DECOMMISSION
PLATFORM. ONCE THAT LEASES
ISSUED AND PRODUCTION AND SUSE
THE COMPANY CONTINUED TO
PRODUCING AS LONG AS THEY WANT
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS-
LOBBYIST. EVERITT STALLED WHAT
YOU DON'T SIXTIES YEARS AGO ARE
WRAPPING UP THEIR- VIABLE
PRODUCTIVE LIFE AND SO WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE POPCORN SNAPPING
DECOMMISSION WE HAVE EIGHT IN
THE Q. AND AS I MENTIONED I
COULD SEE THAT DOUBLE IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS- SO IT'S NOT TOO
MANY PEOPLE OF THE LAW IT'S BEEN
A ECONOMIC- DETERMINATION BY
THESE- PLATFORM OPERATORS AND
OWNERS. THEY ARE THIRTIES
DECOMMISSIONED- SO NOW LET'S LET
THE LAW WORK. YES THANK YOU
LINDA JUST TIME ADD ON TO THE I
WOULD SAY THAT. SOME OF THE
ISSUES WITH THE LAW OUR-
PRIMARILY WITH THE LIABILITY FOR
THE STRUCTURE ITSELF WHILE THE
WELLS RICH REMAIN WITH THE OIL
COMPANIES SO SHOULD THERE EVER
BE A LEAK OR SPILL THEY'LL
ALWAYS BE RESPONSIBLE THE
LIABILITY FOR THAT PLATFORM
JACKET IT'S NOT CLEARLY STATED
IN AB TWENTY FIVE OH THREE WHO
WOULD. TAKE THAT ON AND SO. IT
WOULD DEFAULT TO THE OIL
COMPANIES TO RETAIN THAT
LIABILITY BUT THE OIL COMPANIES
ARE NOT INTERESTED AND HOLDING
ON TO THE STRUCTURE. MULTIPLE
YEARS DOWN THE LINE AS IT'S
FUNCTIONING AS AN ARTIFICIAL
REEF AND SO IN THE GULF OF
MEXICO WHAT THEY HAVE DONE IS.
THEY HAVE DEVELOPED DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE ARTIFICIAL
REEF AND RIGS TO REEF PROGRAMS
IN LOUISIANA TEXAS MISSISSIPPI
AND THOSE PROGRAMS. MANAGE THESE
STRUCTURES AND TAKE ON THE
LIABILITY AS THEY MANAGE ALL THE
OTHER ARTIFICIAL REEFS UNDER
THEIR JURISDICTION. AND IF WE
WERE TO LOOK AT THE GULF OF
MEXICO AS AN EXAMPLE WE COULD
SAY WE COULD ESTABLISH A RIGS TO
REEF PROGRAM THROUGH OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO TAKE ON THAT LIABILITY. AND
THE LEGISLATION WOULD NEED TO
HAVE SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO
ACCOMMODATE FOR THAT TRANSFER OF
LIABILITY AND MAKE IT CLEAR OF
THAT SPECIFIC PATHWAY AND SO
THAT COULD BE ONE OPTION THAT
WOULD POTENTIALLY. MAKE IT AN
INCENTIVIZE BOTH THE OIL
COMPANIES AND THE STATE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS LAW AND
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL SENATE
BILLS THAT HAVE. TRIED TO MAKES
CERTAIN REVISIONS FOR THE LAW TO
MAKE IT. YOU KNOW MORE.
ACCEPTABLE BY THIS STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED BUT NONE OF THOSE HAVE
EFFECTIVELY CHANGE THE LAW. IF I
MIGHT ADD ON TO THAT- RIGHT AND
NOW WE'RE RUNNING SHORT ON TIME
I'D JUST LIKE TO RESPOND REAL
QUICKLY FIRST OF ALL- THERE HAVE
BEEN EFFORTS TO CHANGE- AB- FIVE
OH THREE NONE OF THEM HAVE DEALT
WITH THE LIABILITY ISSUE THEY'VE
ALL DEALT WITH TRYING TO WEAKEN.
THE SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS NUMBER
TWO AND THE GULF OF MEXICO THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY NATURAL ROCKY
WEEK HABITAT SO THEY KIND OF
VIABLE. ARTIFICIAL REEF PROGRAM
FOR YEARS AND THE WAY THEY'VE
ADAPTED TO MAKE ST AS- THEY HAVE
SET ARTIFICIALLY SITES AT THE
STATE DOES MANAGE PRIMARILY FOR
RECREATIONAL FISHING. THEY ALLOW
CLOUT FROM OPERATORS TO
CONTRIBUTE SOME MATERIALS TO
THOSE REVIEW SITES THEY DON'T GO
AROUND AND MANAGE EVERY SINGLE
PLATFORM- OPERATOR DOESN'T WANT
TO REMOVE. THAT WOULD BE
UNTENABLE SO UP.FOR THE MOST
PART I KNOW SOMETIMES PLATFORMS
REMAIN A PLACE BUT FOR THE MOST
PART THEY ARE REMOVED AND THE
COMPANIES THAT CAN CONTRIBUTE
SOME MATERIALS TO. A SET MANAGED
RECREATIONAL FISHING A REEF SO
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT THAT WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND- I CAN TELL YOU
I'VE WORKED ON. ALL THE BILL
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
ONLY READ AB TWO FIVE OR PASS
WHAT BECAUSE OF IN DOWN TO.
PROVISION STATE NOT WANT
LIABILITY IN PERPETUITY FOR THE
SITES- IT'S JUST NOT
ECONOMICALLY STE- RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE STATE TO DO. WELL THANK
YOU BOTH I HAD. A QUESTION FROM
SOMEONE OF THEM- NOT NOT A
QUESTION REALLY- A COMMENT
PERHAPS THAT'S A NOTE OF
CAUTION- I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT TO OTHERS A LOT OF FOUGHT
THAT'S BEING CUT PUT AN- END TO
THIS PROGRAM- BUT I HAVE TO PUT
HIM EXTREMELY UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
THE ENTIRE TOPIC AND THE REASON-
IS. FACTUAL AND EMOTIONAL FOR ME
WE'VE BEEN USING THE OCEANS AS
OUR GARBAGE CANS WHEN I SAY WE I
MEAN. THE HUMAN RACE HAS BEEN
USING THE OCEANS AS OUR GARBAGE
CANS FOR CENTURIES- YOU KNOW
WE'VE THROWN EVERYTHING FROM
PLASTIC BAGS TO- THINGS THAT
BREAK DOWN INTO MICROPLASTICS TO
FISHING LINE AND FOLKS SURE I
MEAN WE FOR YOU FOR YEARS BOTH
WERE JUST SUNK IN PLACE- SPARE
TIRE AND NOT SPARE TIRES USED
TIRES- THAT EVERYTHING UNDER THE
SUN. IS SITTING ON THE FLOOR OF
THE OCEAN WHY DO WE NOT PAY THAT
MUCH ATTENTION TO IT WE DON'T
SEE IT- BUT IT IT IS POLLUTING
AND FOLLOWING GOT WATER AROUND
THE GLOBE. AND. I YOU KNOW I
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE STRUCTURES
ARE OUT THERE AND WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO WITH THEM-
YOU KNOW NOW THAT THEY'RE OUT
THERE ALREADY BUT THE UNTANGLING
OF THIS PROBLEM- IS ONE. THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO GIVE AN EXTREME
AMOUNT OF THOUGHT TO- AND NOT
JUST. CONCEPTUALLY THINK WELL
YOU KNOW WE GET TO TURN THIS
INTO A ROOF IT'S LEFT OVER
GARBAGE THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
TRANSITION TO SOMETHING THAT'S
USEFUL BUT IT'S STILL GARBAGE-
AND WE DON'T THINK ABOUT THIS IN
THE CONTEXT OF MAYBE THAT THE
STRUCTURE SHOULD BE THERE IN THE
FIRST PLACE- THERE'S A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF. I'LL BE SELF
CRITICAL- IN IN MAKING THIS
STATEMENT I BELIEVE AN OFFSHORE
WIND YOU KNOW SO THERE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO BE STRUCTURES FOR
THAT- I JUST WANT US TO NOT BE
ONLY THINKING ABOUT. THIS FROM-
YOU KNOW A SINGULAR PERSPECTIVE-
WE SHOULD BE THINKING
HOLISTICALLY ABOUT THIS PROBLEM-
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST THE- OF
THE OIL RIGS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT NEEDS TO
BE CLEANED UP IN THE OCEAN. YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS I HAVE IF I MAY RESPOND
TO THAT I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
WHAT YOU'RE WHO. ARE SAYING AND
I THINK THAT THIS REALLY CALLS
TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS THAT IS BEING PRESENTED
TO US THROUGH THE- THROUGH THE
EIS AND THROUGH OUR SEQUEL
PROCESS WE CAN REALLY RELY ON
THAT AS AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
LOOKING AT. USING PORTENT
ENVIRONMENTAL DECISIONS THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE WITH A PROBLEM THAT
YORK THEY FROZE SUBWAY CARS AND
YOU'RE RIGHT TIRES OFF OF
FLORIDA. AND OUR OCEANS ARE NOT
A DUMPING GROUND AND THIS IS A
MOMENT WHERE WE NEED TO LOOK AT
AN EXISTING PROBLEM AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE BEST
ENVIRONMENTAL OPTION IS. AND I
THINK THAT WE CAN FALL BACK ON
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT
PROCESSES THAT ARE IN PLACE SO
THAT WE CAN COME TO THE BEST
DECISION FOR OUR PLANET FOR
PEOPLE HERE. THANK YOU. APPLE
THANK YOU AGAIN I. MISS CROP
AND- INSPECTS FOR BEING HERE AND
JOINING US EFFORT FOR THE
HEARING REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
INSIGHT AND PERSPECTIVE. I WITH
THAT WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND ADD TRANSITION TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS. I INDIVIDUALS
ONCE AGAIN WHO WISH TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC COMMENT-
AT THE TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE AGAIN IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO Q. AND- I
WILL ASK SPEAKERS TO LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES- IN
ORDER TO ENSURE TIME FOR ALL.
PARTICIPANTS IF THERE'S ANYONE I
IN THE PUB AT ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WHO IS HERE IN THE ROOM.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND- I'LL
GO AHEAD AND INVITE YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. PLEASE. SOME OF MY. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES HI- GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME IS
NATALIE CHAPMAN I AM A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS- AND THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY AND
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM I'VE BEEN
RESEARCHING THE OFFER OIL
DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS FOR FOUR
YEARS THROUGHOUT MY UNDERGRAD
AND THEN NOW I CONTINUING ON
WITH IT I DO HAVE AN AFFILIATION
WITH A LOT OF HIS FOUNDATION AS
AN INTERN WITH THEM BUT- I LIKE
TO JUST SAY AND POINT OUT THAT
THERE. COULD BE A REALLY-
INTERESTING POTENTIAL FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES AS SOME OF
OUR PANELISTS TODD ALSO SAID
TODAY- I ALSO PUSHING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S INITIATIVES AND
GOALS SUCH AS THE COP THE THIRTY
BY THIRTY INITIATIVES AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONSERVE AND
HOPEFULLY BRIDGE- INDUSTRY AND
ALLOW FOR CONSERVATION INDUSTRY
TO- INTERMIX IN A WAY THAT
HASN'T HISTORICALLY BEEN
ALLOWABLE- AND ALL. HOPEFULLY
SAID A PRECEDENT FOR FUTURE
WORKS IN CONSERVATION. AND THAT.
WE CARE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS TO
OUR OCEANS FOR EXAMPLE WE CARE
WITH THESE ARE MINDFUL DECISIONS
THAT ARE HAPPENING. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE SETTING A
PRECEDENT AS WE CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP AND MAKE- BEST MANAGER
BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AND
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT. AND GENERAL
AND I RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
EXTRACTIONS SO JUST MOVING
FORWARD- WE CAN USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SET THAT
PRECEDENT- SUSTAINABILITY AND
THINKING OF WHOLE LIFE
STRUCTURES AND WHOLE LIFE-
IMPLICATIONS OF WHAT WE DO WITH
OUR- RESOURCES HERE CALIFORNIA.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
TIME- I REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S INSIGHTFUL COMMENTS
AND THE PANELISTS. AND
ESPECIALLY- THE OPPORTUNITIES
WITH YOU TODAY AND I WOULD ALSO
YEAH I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING HOW
THE STATE- HANDLES THE
INTERESTING INTERSECTION OF
INDUSTRY CONSERVATION AND THE
PUBLIC UNTIL SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. FIFTEEN I KNOW MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM MACHINE
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME I'LL GO
AHEAD AND- WILL OPEN UP THAT
TURNED IT OVER TO OUR MODERATOR
TO OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IF YOU ARE ON A SPEAKER
PHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND ONE CHEN MY
NUMBER. IS PROVIDED. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
IF NECESSARY AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON TODAY'S
CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND IN
GENERAL AT THIS TIME NINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT.
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- MEMBERS- OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHRIS HANNAN AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE FORTY AN
AFFILIATE AND HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE LOS
ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY'S.
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL- I STAND IN SOLIDARITY-
AND ALL OF OUR MEMBERS STAND
VOLUNTARY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA- ARE BUILDING
TRADE UNIONS ARE PARTNERSHIPS
ARE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS TO GO TO
WORK- THIS INCLUDES CALIFORNIA
THAT- REPORTLINKER. CALIFORNIANS
THAT GIRL BEEN- UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND WE GO TO WORK
EVERY DAY- OPERATED PROJECTS
INCLUDING PROJECTS IN THE OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRY- ARTIFICIALLY-
ELIMINATING LOCAL PRODUCTION-
THE ENERGY NEEDS FOR CALIFORNIA
IS SHORT SIGHTED- WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY SOURCES
WORLD. WAR COMMITTED TO WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE STATE TO MEET
CLIMATE GOALS- BUT ARTIFICIALLY-
ENDING LOCAL PRODUCTION WALL-
WHILE CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL
USING IT DOES NOTHING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM IT IT'S- WORSE FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE THERE'S
NO PLACE THAT HAS. ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS HIGHEST CALIFORNIA-
WHEN WE WORK TOGETHER- THE WIND
PROJECT WE HAVE RECEIVED BIRTH
DISPENSED OR- HERE LOCALLY IN
THE COURT- YOU KNOW ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE WORKING
TOGETHER ON ALTERNATIVE FUELS
FOR THE AVIATION INDUSTRY WERE
RECEIVING PUSHBACK IN PARAMOUNT.
IT'S NOT A COUPLE JOBS WE HAVE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS. THAT
ARE GOING TO GO TO WORK. EVERY
DAY ON THAT WERE AND- FOR. FUELS
THAT ARE GOING HELP SUPPLY ABA
AND- WITH- WITH. THE ANIMAL
FEELS WERE WERE SAYING BLOCKS
ALL OVER THE PLACE WE NEED TO BE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THIS AND I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE BY THE STATE BUILDING TRADE
THE ERROR MADE. WE NEED TO BE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THIS WE NEED TO
MOVE GOOD PROJECTS BUT WE SHOULD
BE SO SHORT SIGHTED IT. TAKES A
LOT OF WORK TO KEEP A HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND MEMBERS BUSY.
ANYONE OF LOS ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS ARE NOW
APPRENTICES JUST BEGINNING THEIR
CAREER AND TO PULL THE RUG OUT
FROM UNDERNEATH THEM WHILE
THEY'RE TRAINING- IS JUST THE
WRONG DECISION TO MAKE RIGHT
NOW. I STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- YEAH THIS IS- JEFF ON A
LOCKER WITH THE- HUMBLE DON'T
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THE SPEAKER BEFORE. BUT TRULY
HOME TO MAKE IT SHORT AND SWEET-
ERIN DID YOU YOU DID FROM- A
GREAT JOB- FROM THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES AND WE SUPPORT
ALL OF THE COMMENTS FROM THE
STRAIGHT STATE BUILDING TRADES-
REGARDING THIS SO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND WE
GOT TO WATCH OUT FOLKS WHAT WE
DO. BECAUSE WE'RE PUTTING PEOPLE
OUT OF WORK AND WE HAVE TO HAVE
JOBS BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT SO
CAN WE NEED TO STUFF.
UNFORTUNATELY SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LAUREN CALM POLICY ADVOCATE FOR
KIRKUK CAL REPRESENTING THIRTEEN
CAP AND HAPPENED MEMBERS
SUPPORTERS THE STATE I'D LIKE
THANK THE CHAIR MEMBER OF THIS
CAN. OF ALL THE FOR THE AND THE
CA ON THE FERRY IMPORTANT AS THE
STATE IS WORKING TRANSITIONING
OFF FOSSIL FUELS EVERYONE IN THE
STATE OF KNOWN FOR DECADES THAT
OIL DRILLING WHETHER OFFSHORE OR
ONSHORE IS DANGEROUS AND HARMFUL
FOR COMMUNITY PUBLIC HEALTH
ECOSYSTEMS AND CLIMATE WE'RE
LONG PAST THE TIME TRYING TO
TRANSITION AWAY FROM DANGERS
WILL DRAWING AND TRANSITION
TOWARDS A HEALTHIER. PAPER CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE AND ALTHOUGH THE
HEARING OF PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING AND
DECOMMISSIONING THE CONVERSATION
HERE WILL ALSO BE IMPORTANT FOR
DECOMMISSIONING AND REMEDIATION
PROCESSES THAT WILL HAPPEN ON
SHORT SO I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY TEAM IN THE
COMING WITH ENERGY HE AND OTHERS
TODAY AND REITERATE THE NEED TO
HOLD THOSE ESPONSIBLE PARTIES
AND INDUSTRY ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
MASSIVE LEFT BEHIND. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO UPHOLD THE POLLUTER
PAYS PRINCIPLE IN CALIFORNIA THE
STATE'S NOT BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PAYING THE COST OF CLEANING UP
THE POLLUTION HAZARD OF THE OIL
INDUSTRY WE ARE COUNTING ON THE
STATE TO ENSURE THAT AS WE
TRANSITION AWAY AND SHUT DOWN
OIL EXTRACTION. ALL PARTIES
WHETHER THAT'S SPECIFIC. OR THE
INDUSTRY A WHOLE. BUT THE ONE
PAYING FOR THE DOWN OF WELCOME
ANY ROOM YOU. THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN. MANY OF. TO BE MADE TO
ENSURE THE CALL CAN OUR COVER
FROM THE SPOT PARTIES ARE FROM
THE END. AS A WHOLE HOW TO THE
PER ALL. FEET AWAY FIND WE ALSO
NEED TO BE. BY MARK. INCREASE TO
ENSURE THE STATE FINANCE
COMPLETED FROM. CLOSURE CALL. WE
ARE COUNTY ON THE THREE DECISION
MAY TO CREATE CLEAR PA. THAT
WILL PROTECT THE STATE TAXPAYER
AN INCH. DE COSTS ARE RIGHTLY
COVERED BY THE END OF. THANK YOU
CAN PRETTY OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT YOUR CALL CALIFORNIA
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING THE
LEGISLATURE. ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE OPEN GO AHEAD. HI I'M
ONE TWENTY EIGHT AND I REPRESENT
ALL OF THE CONCERNED CITIZENS
WHO ARE WATCHING THIS- GREEN
AGENDA GET FORCED IT DOWN OUR
THROATS AND I'D LIKE TO READ
FROM A DOCUMENT AP ARE A ERA
GREAT TODAY'S BETTER TOMORROWS.
SIX REASONS WHY CALIFORNIA NEEDS
THE OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION THE
GOLDEN STATE CONSUMES EVERY
BARREL OF OIL AND GAS PRODUCED
YEAR AND IMPORTS SO WAY WAY MORE
OTHER QUICK FACTS ABOUT THE
INDUSTRY THAT POWERS CALIFORNIA.
NUMBER ONE CALIFORNIANS USE OIL
AND NATURAL GAS EVERY DAY AS
PART OF OUR DAILY LIVES NUMBER
TWO OIL AND NATURAL GAS POWER
KANEMI ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IN
STATE AND LOCAL TAX REVENUE TO
FUND VITAL COMMUNITY SERVICES
EDUCATION HEALTH AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. FIFTY THOUSAND HIGH
PAYING JOBS FOR WORKING FAMILIES
FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS THIRTY
ONE THOUSAND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY A SAFE AFFORDABLE AND
RELIABLE ENERGY SUPPLY THAT
FUELS CARDS HE TOLD SPORTS
BUSINESSES GROSS FOOD AND
PRODUCES EVERYDAY PRODUCTS.
REGIONALLY ABOUT THREE QUARTERS
OF IN STATE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION OCCURS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHERE THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE IS ALREADY TWO POINT ONE
PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER THAN
THE REST OF THE STATE. NUMBER
THREE CALIFORNIA OIL AND GAS IS
PRODUCED UNDER SOME OF THE MOST
STRINGENT REGULATIONS IN THE
WORLD- ALL PRODUCED BY FOREIGN
SOURCES ISN'T SUBJECT TO THE
RIGOROUS ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
GREENHOUSE GAS MITIGATION AND
WORKER SAFETY INSPECTIONS
PRESENT IN CALIFORNIA NUMBER FOR
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A LOCAL OIL AND
NATURAL GAS PRODUCTION TO ENSURE
RELIABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
FOR CONSUMERS. CALIFORNIA
CONSUMES ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
BARRELS OF OIL A DAY TO MEET ITS
ENERGY NEEDS ABOUT ONE QUARTER
OF OIL AND GAS IS PRODUCED IN
STATE. THE REST OF IMPORTED FROM
DOMESTIC AND RE. CALIFORNIA
CONSUME EVERY BATTLE OF OIL AND
PRODUCED IN THE STATE NEUTRALIZE
OF CRUDE OIL PIPELINE
INFRASTRUCTURE CALIFORNIA IS
DISCONNECTED FROM THE OTHER
LOWER FORTY EIGHT. TWENTY
SECONDS I COULD GO ON AND ON AND
INSTEAD I LISTEN TO YOU WHAT
MAKERS DISMISSED THE ACT BURKE
IN THE OIL INDUSTRY- I
UNDERSTAND WAY MORE THAN YOU
PEOPLE EVER WILL YOU'RE ASKING
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE WORDS.
THANK YOU MY- LET'S GO TO THE
CALL THINK YOU. ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MIKE WEST AND I REPRESENT THE
MEN AND WOMEN OF DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES HUNDREDS OF MEN
AND WOMEN WORKING IN THE
REFINERIES TODAY RATHER THAN
ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES. I WANT TO SPEAK TO
YOU ON A HISTORIC AND COMMON
SENSE- ISSUE IF YOU LOOK BACK AT
THE INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION
STARTING BACK. WHEN BURNING COAL
AND THE STEAM ENGINE WAS THE
ORDER OF THE DAY AND THE
TRANSITION BETWEEN THAT AND OIL
REFINING AND THE INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE. THOSE
TRANSITION TOOK DECADE. AND THE
CURRENT INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION
THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW IT'S
CALLED RENEWABLE ENERGY SO NOW
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU ANOTHER
ANALOGY I WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE LATE SEVENTIES AND EARLY
EIGHTIES AND I DID MY REPORT BY
DOING RESEARCH AND BOOK AN
ENCYCLOPEDIA WELL WE DIDN'T
THROW AWAY THE ENCYCLOPEDIAS
UNTIL WE HAD THE INTERNET SO MY
POINT BEING IS THAT- WE HAVE TO
LET INNOVATION OF THE RENEWABLE
ENERGY TAKE PLACE BEFORE THE
TRANSITION AWAY FROM THAT MAKES
SENSE. SO ANYTHING SHORT OF THAT
IS BULLISH AND SHORT SIGHTED BUT
ALSO RECKLESS SO WITH THAT SAID-
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS LAUREN CHASE I AM A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH ORANGE COUNTY
COAST KEEPER OUT BUT BEYOND THAT
I AM A BECAUSE YOU MISTER
RESIDENT I'M AN ORANGE COUNTY
THIRD FOR- AND- AN ADVOCATE FOR
DECOMMISSIONING WE HAVE
PLATFORMS OFFER CLOSE BY HAD
THIRTY FIVE YOUR ESTIMATED
LIFESPAN AND HAVE NOW LIVED LONG
PAST THAT. THEY'RE BEING HELD UP
BY FEDERER WORLD P. RELIEF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE MAKING THEM
ARTIFICIALLY PROFITABLE EARLIER
YOU HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC TERM FOR THE LEE SAYS I
JUST IN TWENTY TWENTY AMPLIFY
ENERGY'S. REALTY RAGE RATIONALLY
SLICED IN HALF BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- ALLOWING THEM TO
CONTINUE OPERATING THEIR LEASES
WHEN THEY MAY NOT OF BEEN
PROFITABLE- CURRENTLY FIVE OUT
OF SEVEN OF OUR OFF SHORE
PLATFORMS ARE SHUT DOWN DUE TO
LEAKING PIPELINES EARLIER WE
HEARD SOME QUESTIONING ABOUT
WHETHER THERE WOULD BE OTHER
SPELLS IN. QUESTION THAT HAD AN
IMPACT THEIR HOT BUTTON- THE POP
OF PIPELINE CONNECTING POP OR
EVEN TO SHORE ACTUALLY GONE TO
BE LEAKING AND DECEMBER WHICH
HAS RESULTED IN PRIVATE SEVEN OF
OUR PLATFORMS CURRENTLY BEING
SHOT AND- SO I APPRECIATED WOMAN
BRINGING. ALL THESE GROUPS
TOGETHER HERE TODAY TO MEET AND
DISCUSS AND PARTICULARLY THE
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL IT'S
IMPORTANT YOU'RE ALREADY WAITED
IN THIS CONVERSATION- BUT I'M
ALSO OF THE CAMPSITE THE TREE
WILL ACTUALLY SAVE THE PERSON
FOR THIS IS NOT A BINARY CHOICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
OVER HERE TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE ENGAGING ON
THE REALLY CRUCIAL. ISSUE YEAH.
NINE TWO NINE YOUR IS OPEN GO A
- HELLO MY NAME IS MUCH MORE AND
I AM SOUTHERN FIELD REPS FOR THE
NON OR- OCEAN WHICH IS THE
LARGEST. ADDICT YOUR DEDICATED
SOLELY TO OCEAN CONSERVATION
FIRST I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN HOW
DO YOU PATRICK NORRIS RESPONSE
THE OIL SPILL OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS I ALSO WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THINK TEARS RIVAS LOAN
AND ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
CALIFORNIANS ARE UNITED IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO OFFSHORE DRILLING
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
MUNICIPALITIES ON THE WESTCOAST
THE GOVERNORS OF CALIFORNIA
OREGON AND WASHINGTON THE
BUSINESS ALLIANCE FOR PROTECTING
PACIFIC COAST ALLIANCE THAT
REPRESENTS MORE THAN SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED BUSINESSES.
NUMEROUS FISHING INTERESTED
INCLUDING THE PACIFIC FISHERY
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL AND THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION
OFFICIAL ASSOCIATION OF ALL OF
THE FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION AND CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMMISSION HAVE ALL
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT FOR
FORMALLY OPPOSED. EXPANDED
OFFSHORE DRILLING. R. COSTA MAN
THE JOB THAT PROVIDES DEPEND ON
STREETS OUR OF. CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN COAST ECONOMY SUPPORTS
AROUND SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR. JOBS AND ABOUT FIFTY FOUR
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
GDP THROUGH ACTIVITIES LIKE
TOURISM RECREATION AND FISHING.
I'M NOT TIME WHEN WE ARE FACED
WITH INDUSTRY BECAUSE THE DOCTOR
WE ARE TOLD BY THOSE RESPONSIBLE
BUT WILL STILL ARE JUST RARE
OCCURRENCES. THE RUPTURED
PIPELINE AND ENSURING STILL HAVE
BEEN A TRAGIC COMBINATION OF
WHAT WE HAVE NOTS FOR FAR TOO
LONG. AFTER DRILLING IS DIRTY
AND DANGEROUS AND WHEN THEY
DRILL THEY SELL. FROM
EXPLORATION TO DRAWING TO
EXTRACTION TO TRANSPORTATION
OFFERED YELLING THREATENS THE
DOCTOR AT EVERY STAGE. IN FACT
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE ARE OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND OIL SPILLS IN
FEDERAL WATERS AN AVERAGE OF
ABOUT TWO EVERY SINGLE DAY. THE
MAJOR SO WE JUST EXPERIENCE IS
NOT AN ISOLATED EVENT. REMEMBER
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN THERE SHOULD
YOUR BEACH OIL SPILL DUMPED
THOUSANDS OF FERAL TOP OIL ONTO
CALIFORNIA'S BIOLOGICALLY
DIVERSE COASTLINE. REMEMBER THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF GALLONS
OF OIL SPILLED INTO THE GULF OF
MEXICO IN TWO THOUSAND TEN BY
DEEP. DEEPWATER HORIZON. ALONG
OF OUR OCEANS REMAIN OPEN TO
MARSHALLING MORE TOXIC OIL
SPILLS WILL OCCUR. AFTER
EXPERIENCING ALSO DISASTER AFTER
DISASTER THERE'S JUST. EXCUSE
FOR. OF COURSE TO REMAIN OPEN
TOP OR- FOR OIL POLLUTION DEGREE
. GAS EMISSIONS IT'S WELL TIME
TOPIC. OUR DRILLING AND CRIMINAL
PROTECT COAST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THE
MIDDLE BATTLE WITH THE IRON
WORKERS DISTRICT COUNCIL HI WE
CAN IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
PROVINCIAL- JUST A QUICK NOTE IN
ORDER TO MEAN- ON YOU KNOW
STATEWIDE YORK WE ARE THE HOBBIT
ENERGY GENERATION. THANK YOU.
THANKS INTO A CORNER YOU KNOW.
WIND IN HIGH IN ADDITION A
CURRENT AND UNABLE TO EVEN OUT
OF THE- FOR. BECAUSE THE DAMAGE
ACROSS THE STATE. OKAY CAN'T
BUILD OF THE CELL NEEDED SPURRED
THE GREEN ENERGY WE CAN HELP US
BUT WE NEED HOW GONNA CLOWN.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME. AND
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARCHITECT
MADAM CHAIRMAN THIS IS JANE
THROW OUT WITH THE K. STATE
COUNCIL OF PAPERS. THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING TODAY'S HEARING AND
ALLOWING FOR ROBUST IN IN DEPTH
DISCUSSION REGARDING BOTH THE
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH DECOMMISSIONING.
LIKE A JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS
AND CONCERNS THE REPORTING THE
ARTICULATED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE STATE BOTH TRADES. LABORS
REPRESENT OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
MEN AND WOMEN STATEWIDE GO WORK
IN HEAVY CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS WORK
DIRECTLY IN BUILDING AND
MAINTAINING OUR STATE ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT IS CRITICAL
THAT ARE WORKING FAMILIES ARE
NOT JUST CONSIDER. I RATHER
PRIOR- IN ANY FUTURE CAR.
REGARDING POTENTIAL TRANSITIONS
WITHIN OUR ENERGY RESOURCES.
AFTER TODAY'S HEARING I AM VERY
OPTIMISTIC AND ENCOURAGED BY THE
COMMENTS MADE BY A NUMBER OF THE
MEMBERS- I LIKED IT JUST
RESPECTFULLY ACTIVISM SEAT AT
THE TABLE AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER AND FINDING THE
RIGHT BALANCE THAT PROTECTS OUR
WORKERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE COMING Q. AT THANK YOU
MODERATOR I AND WITH THAT AT
HAVE REACHED THE CONCLUSION OF
TODAY'S HEARING. AS WHEN IT JUST
THANK ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS I CHAIR
THREE OF US AND DIED CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM. OFF FOR
HELPING US PLANETARY NO IT ALSO
JUST LIKE TO THANK OUR TEAMS WHO
WORKED REALLY HARD PARTICULARLY-
I HAVE MY EYES STAFF MEMBER
SHANNON SWANSON THANK YOU SO
MUCH- AND I THINK AS WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL OF THE PANELISTS WHO
JOINED US TODAY AT. THE HYATT
CONSIDERATIONS FOR
DECOMMISSIONING OFFSHORE OIL
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA ARE ARE
AND- VERY COMPLEX AND I BELIEVE
THAT TODAY'S HEARING AND THE
FUTURECONVERSATIONS AND-
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE WILL PLAN
WITH- STAKEHOLDERS REALLY WILL
HELP SHAPE THE COMING YEARS OF
MAKING OUR STATE AND PLANET A
CLEANER AND SAFER PLACE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO JOINED US TODAY FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU ON A
COLLABORATIVE STRATEGY TO ENSURE
THAT WE WORK TOGETHER TO PHASE
OUT AFTER OIL PRODUCTION ON THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA. AT WITH
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TV'S WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT AND I AND I'VE I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER I THINK YOU HAD
GREAT PANELISTS AT A LOT
INFORMATION I LEARNED SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT- WE HEARD A LOT
TODAY AND I THINK THAT ONE THING
IS CLEAR- WE ARE NOWHERE NEAR.
READY TO BEGIN FORMAL POLICY
DISCUSSIONS ON THE COMMISSION
OFF SHORE OIL- AS WE MENTIONED
BY HE VILLAGE TRADES WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE WORKERS FIRST AND
FOREMOST AND ENSURE ANY POLICY
WHEN ACT HAS PROVISIONS TO
PROTECT WORKERS AND ENSURE THEY
CAN CONTINUE THEIR LIVELIHOOD
THE STATE NEEDS DRASTICALLY
INCREASE ITS RETRAINING AND
RELOCATION FUNDING. THE CURRENT
AMOUNT TO IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET RIGHT NOW IS QUITE
PITIFUL I WILL CLOSE MY REMARKS
BY REMINDING MEMBER TODAY. IT'S
A ONE YEAR. WHEN THE CURRENT
INVESTIGATION THE ANCHOR STRIKE
HAPPENED. I HAVE INTRODUCED AB%
SIX ELEVEN TO ENSURE THAT ANY
ANCHOR STRIKE IS REPORTED
IMMEDIATELY TO NUMBER OF STATE
AGENCIES I WELCOME ALL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO CO AUTHOR THIS BILL.
PREVENT ANOTHER DISASTER WITHOUT
SHUTTING DOWN OR INDUSTRY THANK
YOU CAN I LOOK FOR TO FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS ISSUE. AND
THANK YOU AND WITHOUT- WE ARE
ADJOURNED.